good morning everybody being 9 33.
3 before we open up our public hearings
thank you we're going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 370 FN
relative to aftermarket window tinting
on Motor Vehicles for drivers with
medical conditions
chair recognizes representative yokaila
uh the prime sponsor good morning sir
good morning uh for the record my name
is representative yokella uh from
Rockingham 32 Fremont Danville and
Brentwood
um I am introducing HB 730
um because uh the story really starts a
few years ago in 2021
um when I put in a bill to
um increase or allow side window tinting
on on
passenger vehicles
and the amendment to that bill in 2021
removed the exemption for
uh so the the bill was amended by this
committee and in that Amendment the
exemption for uh side window tinting was
removed
um
for medical waivers there is no more
medical waivers for side window tinting
um in our statute and
uh that
was an unfortunate I don't think it was
intended there was no testimony saying
that
anything has changed as far as medical
necessity for for side window tinting
and
um
I also know that last year there was a
bill
um that that was kind of stemmed from
this uh lack of side window tinting
um
uh medical waiver that adjusted the
windshield uh medical waiver aspect and
there once again was little Fanfare and
no discussion about whether or not it
was appropriate to have the window
tinting for the medical waivers and if
medical waivers were of value right now
the only medical waiver allowed is for
70 which is on windshield and
um
and that erosion of these medical
waivers has essentially
um it's come back and many people have
reached out to me and said you know I I
have had a medical waiver and my car
tinted for many years and now I'm no
longer able to have the the window
tinting
um because it's just not allowed under
our current law and
so I believe that this was an unintended
consequence and so what I'm trying to do
with this bill is to remedy that by
putting back in the language of 6658
Dash a uh Roman 3 Dash a
um that you are allowed to have an
exemption
for Windows of the left and right side
of the driver and
um I'm also
uh
kind of changing the the um the the
process for getting that and right now
you're you have to request it from the
commissioner and they may or may not
have granted depending on
um
essentially what they see is is
if it qualifies based on
it's an unknown whatever is whatever the
the uh requirements or or status that
they're going by even though your doctor
May say that it's required and so what
I'm saying what I am proposing in this
bill is that the um
um
that you're a partic a practitioner that
you have a relationship with can just
attest that
um your you have medical conditions
um which window tinting would reduce the
severity of or would
um
um yes so you've been diagnosed or take
medications that cause a condition which
tinted windows would reduce the severity
of and then
um from the commissioner's span
standpoint they're just going to trust
the doctor unless they believe that the
doctor may be acting in bad faith and
then they might
um uh Ford those those letters on to
their regulating agency if they're if
the doctor is doing something suspicious
and instead of right now they have like
a power to convene a whole kind of
committee as far to decide whether or
not it's appropriate and um and I think
that's if the doctor says you know we
don't question if the doctor writes a
prescription for
for uh you know Xanax or whatever we
don't ask that whether or not that's
appropriate unless it's egregious and
then we would go to the medical go go to
their regulatory agency and and say hey
this is this person is acting in bad
faith I think that should be the same
you know uh process essentially for for
this medical tinting so I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you
thank you I've got a couple quick ones
so you're fine with the current statute
the way it reads in regards to the
windshields
because this just refers to the side
thank you for the question
I I am I am uh saying that it's going
back to 30 so on line 24 to 25 I'm
saying that
um if the doctor
um
the doctor allows the 35 percent
if they say that you need tinting then
you can go up to the 35 just like you
were
um in the previous you know
decades before last year
or in in 2021 so yeah it essentially
reverts to the same practice for medical
waivers that we had in 2021 and before
okay would allow up to 35 on the on the
windshield as well with the waiver uh
one other quick question for you I got
an email from I believe it was an
optometrist uh who had no issues with
the bill the way it was what it was
attempting but mentioned that
photophobia might be a little bit too
General a term
thank you for the question
um
so so I actually reached out to my so
one of the things that previously was an
issue is that you only
um it was construed the language was
construed to only allow doctors to say
that you um need medical tinting but if
you may be seeing uh you know uh uh
primary care provider that is uh uh
registered nurse or some other
um
other doctor that may not be actually of
an MD and so I I pretty much widen this
to saying any medical practitioner that
has a relationship with the patient and
So currently I talked to my eye doctor
they wanted that language change because
they would be able to then do this which
they weren't
previously allowed to and they um I had
my eye doctor look at all of these
um these uh actually he was the one
suggested them to me for the most part
but then um they uh
striking any language since it says my
but not limited to it if you wanna if
you feel like you want to strike
photophobia I don't have a problem
because it's technically not limited to
photophobia if the doctor if the
practitioner believes that the phobia
photophobia meets the statement that
they have to sign then it would still be
allowed even though it's not
specifically delimited in the list
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair I actually have two
or three questions uh but I'll ask one
at a time
um
the first part is on that line uh 24.
I'm trying to make sure I understand it
correctly
does this mean you can tint the windows
up to 65 percent
yes the the when you say light
transmittance then you're talking about
how much light is actually going through
thank you Mr chair
uh
what happens when if a police officer
well it's probably maybe for another
person but have you thought about it but
police officer pulled someone over
that's driving that person's car
that doesn't have the condition I mean
are they going to have a medical card on
thank you for the
question
um so there is as you see online
um 15 to 16 the the commissioner
actually issues a special permit and
um there and the conditions for the
officer I'm just changing the conditions
to the same conditions they were in 2021
so it's no more dangerous or or or
um or harmful to any officer or they
need any less training also New
Hampshire and and the other states
around it also have tinting not for
medical reasons for um down to this
level and so they're traveling into New
Hampshire and and police officers are
already still having to deal with that
issue whether or not this is we're
allowing you know people with medical
conditions to to be able to utilize this
technically because we've had this
conversation before you are correct in
your suspicion
that somebody without the medical
condition themselves is not supposed to
be driving the car with the tent that's
accepted so one more follow-up
yeah thank you Mr last one uh is there
is there an issue why why can't uh these
people I know my my mother had
sensitivity to light but and she wore
sunglasses why can't that continue
thank you for the question
I I don't believe that I sh
um
that sunglasses treat every condition
listed and
um I'm not sure that they would be
appropriate in every situation and I'm
not I'm not really uh
here I guess with the intent to resell
you on the the con the state of the law
that it was two years ago it it was the
law and we didn't have really any
testimony that that it needed to change
and I believe that it was an
unintentional change and not like
something that went through rigorous
process that we needed to you know you
know medical weight people coming and
saying this was no longer needed and we
should reduce it that was not
um my understanding of the testimony and
so I believe that it was an unintended
and not
um so I
I don't want to to say that I'm the you
know Medical Professional that said that
this is the best solution
any other questions
see you then thank you very much thank
you
chair recognizes Lieutenant O'Leary from
the Department of Safety
chairman
members of the committee I just wanted
to speak briefly on part of this so the
medical waiver going back to the way
that it was previously we have no issue
with this has been back and forth as we
know we're good with the way that that
part's written my only concern and it's
uh only because I'm not sure what this
new process would look like
um excuse me lines 25 and 26 that speak
to the commissioner forwarding any sworn
statements to licensing agency for the
practitioner to review suspicious waiver
submission so the way that the way that
it works currently in the law
the commissioner is allowed to seek the
advice of the medical Review Board in
order to determine if a person you know
is eligible for such a waiver
this would this new wording would remove
that ability and rely solely on the
licensing agency to then review it
the process works right now with an
application the application being made
to the DMV if there's fraudulent
information on that application or if
somebody's attempting to obtain one of
these waivers fraudulently the
application process allows for denial
allows for the petitioner for a hearing
it allows for state police to involve be
involved in a criminal investigation
that's the way the process currently
Works my concern with the new wording it
would remove that and rely solely on a
letter from a doctor and now widening up
the the people that could provide that
and I understand the concerns on adding
the optometrists and the
ophthalmologists and totally understand
all that part of it but the addition of
any other medical practitioner then
opens up the door to my podiatrist
writing a letter for me and now without
the commissioner having the ability to
seek the advice of a medical board
there's not a process in place
essentially to protect the DMV in that
area so for those reasons I would ask
that you just consider that part of it
however we do support the 35 percent on
the medical waiver
and I'll be happy to take any questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you
the language in the proposed bill says
that the commissioner shall
issue a medical waiver is that the same
language as the old version
it seems to me that that preempts any
possibility to
take a look at each individual statement
as it arrives on his desk his or her
desk thank you Mr representative Sykes
yes it currently says that the
commissioner May waive the requirements
so they have the ability he does have
seeing none thank you very much
having no one else signed up to speak on
House Bill 370 when it closed the public
hearing
uh next up we have at 10 o'clock I was
foreign
okay
okay being 1002 I'm gonna open up the
public hearing on House Bill 537 event
permitting vehicles to have front
windshield tinting Prime sponsor did
reach out to me uh chair recognizes
representative sellers to introduce the
bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm a representative Alvin C I
represent Merrimack County District 26.
um House Bill 537
is a bill that removes the prohibition
did anybody have any questions or was it
just it's a courtesy introduction
correct emergency introduction for uh
representative yep uh thank you next
step chair recognizes Dan weed uh
representative assuming the tempting
industry
good morning thank you
my name is Dan weed I represent Weed
family automotive and the inspection
industry not so much the tinting
industry
I'd like to start out by saying that for
the inspection industry the window tint
laws are about as clear as 35 light
transmittance
um the bill as it has presented uh is
questionable as to whether the sponsors
have done their due diligence and
research the industry standards at this
point such as the FM VSS standard number
205 relating to Federal window 10 and
talked about Indus or failed to talk
with industry participants to truly
understand what is being proposed
the FM VSS standard number 205 relating
to window 10 already requires a 70 light
transmittance
I'd like to know how the sponsor
proposes getting new vehicle
manufacturers to adopt 90 light
transmittance only on vehicles sold in
New Hampshire so they will pass our
inspection standards
does the sponsor understand that if this
bill passes as written it will cost the
average motorist a minimum of a thousand
or more dollars to retrofit their
existing vehicles to comply with a 90
light transmittance
does a sponsor realize at this point
that every vehicle knew or used
currently being sold in the state of New
Hampshire would not pass inspection if
the bill is passed as written
I want you to a lot you know consider
that allowing front windshield tint may
also provide prevent a vehicle operator
from being able to see sufficiently at
night allowing a 35 percent light
transmittance is like wearing your
darkest sunglasses at night so how is
that going to enable somebody with
already compromised vision
as I said can you know can you possibly
see with 35 percent tint on your
windshield that pedestrian and dark
clothing walking down the road
if you're in the North country are you
going to be able to see that moose
crossing the road walking down the road
with 35 percent tint on your windshield
and again 90 light transmittance makes
every vehicle on the road today and that
you drove in in violation of a state
inspection standard
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee one
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um just so we're clear what what is the
light transmittance now for new vehicles
that are sold in New Hampshire
it is currently 70 percent
and that is a federal standard so it's
30 and follow up thank you so that means
that it's 30 percent is allowed to be
locked or is it automatically coming in
that way it's automatically coming in
that way okay so just for reference if
you look out the window behind you that
is 30 light transmittance
uh thank you one quick last one
follow-up um
that's is that done by film or is that
done
um and is there any blockage for UVA UVB
with any of that um light transference
so this is built into the glass that is
currently in the cars now so what will
you consider clear glass on any given
car right now is actually measured at 30
percent light transmit with UV blocking
built in it is built thank you very much
you're welcome
further questions from the committee
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair I just want to make
clear he's he's not mentioning in this
in this uh Bill uh 537 anything about 65
flight blockage just so you're aware
right all right so he's saying 90.
you're saying it automatically comes in
at 70. automatically I didn't even do
that is
so I'm just wondering if he's saying can
we add 10 more
so and this is part of the confusion
that industry struggles with if we say
90 light transmittance it's actually
reverses 10 blockage of light sunlight
trans metal so I think what he was
trying to get at was he wants to go as
dark as you know 10 transmittance which
is lower than the 35 standard we already
have adopted for window 10.
so if you can imagine ninety percent of
the light being blocked
as I think where he was trying to go
with this but again that's darker than
further questions from the committee
representative Coker so just to clarify
on this thank you for taking the
question
um so
basically the way that this just so I
make sure I understand it this Bill is
saying anything that has less than 90
percent visible light transmit that
right now we can go the it's it's legal
to go to 35 basically or it's yeah so
what they're they're at 90 you're
lessening what's already out there now
so we currently have an industry
standard set by the feds of 70 percent
so he wants to take that the way this is
written and presented and make it 90 we
would be the only state in the country
requiring 90 in our glass okay so this
is actually restricting it further right
I'm not saying it's not confusing but
can you show me where it talks about the
factory Windows following uh Nitsa codes
because everything I read in here talks
about aftermarket tinting sure so in the
Federal Motor Vehicle Safety standard
number 205 and I have a
piece of it here
it talks about glazing and materials uh
standard number 205 requires 70 light
transmittance in all windows and
passenger vehicles multi-purpose
passenger vehicles motorhomes and trucks
are required to have 70 light transmits
in the windows and windshield and
windows to the immediate right and left
okay I'm still missing where it singles
that out but one last question for me
Isn't 90 percent light transmittance uh
more than 70 percent it is correct thank
you any other questions from the
committee
uh representative Jones
thank you Mr chairman I'm actually kind
of following up on your questions sir
not the aftermarket but the factory like
I have Factory tinting on my car
um and to tell you the truth I don't
know what it is but but
there's a darker shade on the top and it
gets lighter as it goes down
what what is the standard for that is it
so what you're talking about is on your
windshield you have the blue shading on
the top if you will or or correct sir
tan shading and then it gets down to
what we consider clear glass below it
exactly right which is fully accepted in
the current law says that you can have
up to six inches of the top of the
windshield tinted to 35 35 thank you
representative Sinclair
thank you Mr chair
um I I have to admit I've never I've
understood all these the way all this is
explained uh percentage-wise I just
would like to know if this bill was to
pass and I'm I'm facing in traffic
a car that has this if this bill passed
what would I see looking into that car
when I see the driver would I see
anything well yeah so and this is where
the confusion comes in so the way it's
this bill is currently written it's
changing the standard from 70 light
Transmissions which if you really look
at it is is almost clear glass to a
lesser standard of 90 which is
you take away the UV blockage UV
protection and stuff like that that's
built into the glass so our standard
what you would consider clear glass
actually blocks about 30 percent of the
light coming into it
yep
but my question is would I be able to
see the driver in that vehicle facing if
this bill passed yes at 90 yes you would
be able to see it if it was written the
way I believe it was intended to say 10
light transmittance then no you wouldn't
see the driver
okay thank you
well I don't know if that's how it was
supposed to be written um any other
questions from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
I'm still very confused because and I
think a lot of us are here now because
you said the very top six inches is 35
yep right
but then you say in the windshield's
already at 30 correct Factory out of the
factory so I just never seen that before
but so
that 35 on the top that's an additional
tinting to the 30 right but you can have
a you can only have a maximum so if you
have currently have 30 from the factory
you could only add a five percent tint
to maximize that 35.
on top of it
this is one of those examples you
haven't lived until you've dealt with a
window tinting building
because it gets confusing between
transmittance and emittance so right uh
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
do you have any written testimony
doesn't look like
uh chair recognizes Lieutenant O'Leary
from the Department of Safety opposed to
the bill
Mr chairman thank you Mr chair could you
ask for written testimony
um could you provide the committee with
some written testimony
okay thank you
good morning good morning
you ready to make it even more
convoluted
I'm actually just going to try to
clarify a little bit more for you so
I'll give it my best shot I did bring
some examples uh because that's how I
work here so when we talk about the
standard of light trans minutes it's the
amount the percentage of light that's
allowed to come through the window so
this example that I'll pass around so
you could get a better glimpse of it if
you're good with that this example which
is almost clear is 28 per I'm sorry yeah
let me start off wrong this one right
here is 78 percent
so your car windshield is around this
Clarity it allows approximately 70 to 78
light through kind of like this right
this next one that I'll pass around is
28 so when you think of your 35 percent
tint uh the medical waiver we talked
about just prior to this bill it's
darker than this this is 28 light
transmitter
so
um representative Jones to answer your
question earlier that top Sun strip is
third is you know approximately 35
percent with the remainder of your
windshield would be 70 so the only
reason why we really oppose this bill is
because it's it's asking to make the
windshield lighter than what it
currently Is So currently with the
pigments and everything that are inside
when that when that windshield is
manufactured it's at 70 percent if you
pass this law it'll be required that
it's lighter than that it would be 90
percent
and this is very difficult to because we
for a number of years we always thought
the opposite way of the blockage this
sorry that I see that representative
Hill has a question that's all I had to
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman
so if I if I understand your belief of
this bill it would require
the windshield to be removed if this
passes it would require the windshield
to be removed and replaced with the
windshield that allows clearer glass
than what we currently have yes sir yes
thank you thank you for your question
we we can debate that because I still
keep seeing aftermarket which is
different but and I know the argument we
used to have was for the older vehicles
that actually came clear so we were
looking at aftermarkets match the
federal standards right do you know of
any Vehicles now that come from the
factory uh lighter up with less
transmittance
more transmittance than 70 percent
um I would have to say yes because uh
the vehicles that we tested this morning
so approximately 81 so it would be more
than the 70. but still lighter I'm sorry
yeah not darker then yeah correct so so
in your knowledge there are no vehicles
that come from the factory anymore with
completely clear with correct with 100
that's correct okay any other questions
from the committee representative Fox
thank you Mr chair do you think that the
intent of this bill has been miswritten
and that I mean I I know we can't
speculate what the sponsor intended but
um I'm thinking that the sponsor
intended it to be flipped and that 90
percent
should be blocked yeah thank you for
your question representative Fox
um I I can only speculate as you said
however that being the case and looking
the way that this was written and the
last part of it talks about being able
to apply for a medical waiver again like
we spoke about earlier so if that were
the case we were only allowing 10 light
transmitted then the medical waiver
would then make it lighter and they
would have a 35 light transmittance so
um to answer your question to
um it's been mentioned several times
about what the motives of the Prime
sponsor is I'm going to do something
unusual today he didn't reach out to me
when we're done with questions for the
lieutenant I'm going to recess this
hearing and give them an opportunity to
say what it is if I can fit it in our
schedule for the rest of the day
any other questions for lieutenant
O'Leary
representative Coker thank you Mr
chairman um is there is is there any
distinction between aftermarket and
Factory right now in the current law
like is it or do those it doesn't matter
in what way sir so like can if if my
um if I bought a car that had the 20
restricted could I
add another 10 to 15 on that as long as
it doesn't go below the the federal
standard the aftermarket or okay so that
makes sense I'll try to I'll try to
answer a question sorry so
um we you cannot have 35 window tint
left right of the driver windshield
unless this other logos for free medical
waiver so you currently can have on the
windshield only what is uh at the time
of manufacture which we've determined is
approximately 70 and left and right of
the driver aftermarket meaning you can
apply a film to it up to uh 70 currently
is allowed then if your rear windows are
whatever they come through manufacturer
which oftentimes is 35 or less you'll
see like in the SUVs with the dark
Windows those are acceptable if they
come through clear you can't then use
aftermarket window tint to make it 35 so
I don't know if that answers the
question at all representative I uh
can you repeat the last part of that
again in terms of the real Windows yes
so if you have uh typically the way that
you would see this is uh with an SUV it
comes through already with manufactured
tinted windows if for some reason it was
not tinted you are not
um authorized to then apply aftermarket
window tint to make it dark like 35
percent
so we need another bill
okay
uh any other questions from the
committee
well I only have these two examples sir
so
a couple years ago I had one with four
down to 18 I believe did I see another
hand representative Jones
can I just ask you a question sometimes
my uh when I go to the optometrist to
order glasses
uh they'll offer you a tensed that says
they don't talk about the sun glare they
said it reduces nighttime Road glare
um I I wouldn't be qualified to answer
that question representative Jones
unfortunately
thank you
it's a unique idea though windshields
inside windows that actually darkened
and lit just like glasses yeah
um representative Hill
uh thank you Mr chairman
for me
um the best part of having the side
windows tinted is the reflection off the
rear mirrors when someone's behind me
with high beams or whatever
would would this
help at all if if the tinting were
darker
well I I'm kind of thinking this through
as I go here so um the window film
that's that's on the windshield now yes
sir
um
do you are you qualified to know whether
the film is what changes
the light that comes through the side
windows or is it the actual Tint that's
a good question uh representative so uh
to my knowledge the way that the
manufactured Windows uh include a
pigment and a die so when they make the
glass they actually mix that in
and that's how you get your windows and
windshield tinted to the degree that
they are it only allows that allowed
amount of light transmittance when you
use the aftermarket window tint the film
it still allows for that same amount so
it doesn't change the amount of light
transmittance it's just how it's applied
okay anybody else
and we have a late arrival
uh not taking a position on the bill uh
director marasco from the Department of
committee John marasco director of The
Division of Motor Vehicles and
registration supervisor Jeff obedank
um we uh we support everything that was
uh just testified to by Lieutenant
O'Leary in Industry obviously uh
replacing the windshield would not be
prudent in this case we just wanted to
give you perspective on what we see at
the DMV so in my 11 months there I can
tell you that window 10 I know we've
used the word confusing it is confusing
and not only that it generates a lot of
phone calls from elected officials who
are representing their constituents um
of anything ranging from inspection
stations removing tent for people who
had previously medical waivers to
questions to people just not
understanding window 10. so
um we just bring that to your attention
in the hopes that we've heard two bills
this morning on window 10 that maybe at
one point we could I don't know if a
study committee is is something that you
would want to take a look at but to
really come up with a good solid plan so
that something could be pushed out that
people actually understand and
they understand transmittance and what
that means the 70 30 and people actually
can follow the law
I thought you'd have another one I I
would also Echo those thoughts taking a
number of those complaints myself if the
language is confusing for us and we do
it every day I can imagine just how
confusing it is for the public when
they're deciding to put window tint on
one year and then being told they have
to take it off the next year and then
potentially change out a windshield a
third year in a row I mean we're looking
at three years in a row of changing
window tint law and I think that's
creating as much confusion uh for us who
have to manage the program for those who
are trying to figure out if they should
apply it to their vehicles
fair enough thank you any questions from
the committee I think you've given me a
plan
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I think the biggest confusion is the
is the uh What's blocking and what's
letting light through and and so I'm
wondering if there is a
um is there a standard that that is used
from state to state of does everyone do
all of the laws deal with the
transference or do they deal with um the
Restriction what
that may be part of it because I I've
run into people that come from different
parts of the country and say oh no we
have 70 and and come to find out they're
really talking about 30 when it comes to
our laws so is that part of the problem
I I think that's a great question
um
that answers whether or not we should
anybody else
CNN thank you much thank you
I have nobody else signed up but as I
said I'm going to make the rare move of
recessing this and giving the prime
sponsor an opportunity if you can't make
it I'll close it later if I see it's
going to disrupt our schedule I'll close
it later so I'm going to recess House
Bill the public hearing on House Bill
537.
being 1032 I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 356 FN
relative to the application of Motor
Vehicle allows to bicycles
she recognizes the prime sponsor of the
bill representative aveneli avalani
sorry thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is representative Lino avalani from
Carroll County District 4 representing
the towns of Brookfield Effingham
Wakefield Eaton and freedom
I bought this bill on behalf of a
constituent who was unable to be here
today so I would ask the committee to um
thank you sir
um it does happen from time to time any
questions from the committee
and thank you thank you thank you Mr
chairman
they just don't want to speak to House
Bill 356 chair recognizes Bill Lambert
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is Bill
Lambert um State traffic engineer for
the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation I submitted written
testimony
um
that's in front of you I probably should
have kept a copy of it for myself but I
I can probably
um summarize a couple points and a
department doesn't have a position on
the bill but a couple points to consider
one would be that
um the fiscal note that was prepared for
this bill was prepared by the judicial
branch
um presumably if you're going to have a
bill like this it's going to be
different from other states you would
have to have some signing to let people
know otherwise how would they know
there's a bill so the signing costs
would be indeterminate because we don't
know what what the limit would be
um
and again the bill that's passed in New
Hampshire if you could teach everybody
in New Hampshire that the new new law we
get a lot of visitors at a bike go up 93
in a weekend you'll find any number of
vehicles with bikes on them out of state
plate so how would you notify those
folks of the of the law it seem to be
unfriendly to those visitors that are
using uh New Hampshire's road to uh bike
tours
um other than that I'd be happy to
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair
thank you Mr chair this is uh my
question is with regardings to electric
bicycles
any thought about that I mean I see
those on the on roadways all the time
and I'm pretty sure they can do 30 maybe
40 miles an hour unless I'm just
misjudging that but I'm just my question
is what do you think about possibly in
the future looking at some sort of
requirement for those for one mirror
thank you for the question it's a good
question I
I didn't consider that as part of this
this testimony but I I was at a uh
conference a couple of weeks ago when I
was hearing about electric bikes that
can do as much as 90. um and my
perspective a bike that can do 90 is a
motorcycle
um so I would think that they would
follow any of the laws applicable to
motorcycles so again not subject to this
bill necessarily but I I would have
concerns about some of those electric
thank you
kind of off the topic a little bit but
perhaps at some point talking about a
license plate registering since they're
going that fast on our highways
and now we're getting way off topic I
just throw it out there thank you but uh
a conversation for another day
uh any other questions for
the director CNN thank you very much
having no one else signed up to speak
I'm going to close the public hearing on
next up 11 15. see how much I misjudged
this one
I was expecting a room full actually
uh 11 15 I was Bill 386 enjoy your free
the uh actually the prime sponsor of uh
host Bill
357 said he might be available between
quarter of an 11 so hang tight and uh if
he's here maybe we can reopen and then
close the uh the public hearing on that
by 37. okay I'm going to reopen as I
mentioned when the prime sponsor was
available and I knew this was going to
happen when I put the schedule in last
week that's right that's why I put in
this I built in this downtime so I'm
going to reopen the public hearing and
House Bill 537. Jay recognizes
representative hole who's in support of
the bill
thank you chairman members of
transportation for the record
representative hole serving the towns of
Dunbarton Hooksett Allenstown and have
some the bill before you was at the
request of
one of the New Hampshire citizens who
for various reasons would be difficult
to get a medical waiver but wanted to
make sure she could
um add a ceramic tint to the windshield
to allow for dealing with ultraviolet
and infrared and the ceramic tint
windshield films don't block as much in
the visible spectrum they're actually
designed to deal with the non-visible
Spectrum
um my understanding I wasn't here for
the testimony that new cars may actually
have
um transmission levels below the 90 and
if that's the case we should probably
tweak the language a little bit I was
looking at some of the maps nationally
I do know that the state of New York
allows a 70 and I believe the state of
Pennsylvania as well a 70
um windshield as well as front and
driver side and passenger side window
the side windows transmission rate
um most of the states already allow much
darker than that for rear passenger and
rear windshield
New Hampshire is pretty restrictive when
it comes to even the passenger window
driver side sorry the passenger driver's
side
roll down Windows and then the front
windshield so the fact that we're more
restrictive than than States like New
York I think it's something we should
we did have a lot of questions on this
so we'll have one more round if you're
up for it any questions from the
committee
wow I have one representative hill I'll
start it off thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question
um
the the
ceramic coating that you're
um your constituent is looking for right
um what does she do
in in regular life walking down the
street does she have specific glasses
that cover that concern that's a good
question I can ask I do not know the
answer to because it would follow up
please my my question is why she
couldn't continue to use whatever she's
using in real life while she's driving
thank you good question I do know that
the purpose of these films is to deal
with right some of ceramic for
ultraviolet and infrared is to deal with
heating of the cars right that's the
infrared spectrum and damage to things
on the interior which is the ultraviolet
Spectrum
so
thank you any other questions from the
committee
representative Fox
it was uh confusion on the intent as far
as the percentage
um was the initial intent
for you to block 90 or was it
and I and I know you're I know that
you've no clarified the 70 issue with
with new motor vehicles but
um so my understanding I spoke with the
chairman a little bit during the
crafting of the bill that you don't you
don't draft the legislation relative to
how much it blocks you draft legislation
to how much it transmits so it's a
visible transmittance number that's
what's used I believe us wide and all
the states have adopted that set more
visible visible light transmittance
number
and in this case I I wanted something
less than 100 I was not aware at the
time that new vehicles were already
below a hundred I just wanted something
so that the ceramic windshield tints
that are designed for UV and UltraViolet
I mean so ultraviolet and infrared would
so
um
is this bill moot now considering the
constituent that you were concerned
about if you were asking for a 90 and
they're actually getting 70 percent does
she even need
well if new windshields are being sold
at 70 percent I don't think they're
compliant with the law so it makes the
purpose of the bill that much more
important and we should change the 90 to
a 70 in a committee Amendment right if
new windshields are truly at 70 percent
then why don't we make the law compliant
with that
okay if new manufacturers are saying
that the vehicles are transmitting 70
percent of visible light then we should
make this that has not less than 70
percent visible light transmittance in
both places that are three places four
places that it shows up
um
any other questions representative
sellers
thank you Mr chair are you trying to so
if the vehicle is already coming in at
70 are you trying to add another 10 to
it or take away 10 is that the idea with
your 90. so this would not be additive
to what's there this would be an
I was not aware that it was 70 on the
front windshield
um
um I didn't I don't have I have lots of
engineering tools that's my job I don't
write all sorts of meters of All Sorts
but visible light transmittance meters
um representative Hill thank you Mr
chair
um is it your belief that the film The
ceramic film that you're talking about
changes the
uh light transmittance at all
very minimally they're intended to deal
with outside of the visible spectrum
those coatings
follow-up
yeah follow up
um
so would could your bill be amended to
eliminate the uh the percentage that you
have in there and only talk about the
ability to add
ceramic
film I think that would be a great
suggestion
you stole my fire representative Hill uh
just just to be clear we I haven't got
my plan in stone yet but I think after
the hearings we've had on both these
bills and looking at the current
statutes it's pretty confusing so I
think we're going to be going down the
road whether we
uh do work sessions or retain at the
worst but that was my question for you
as well because it seems like ceramic
Coatings uh is is what you're
concentrating on and it does make some
sense any other questions from the
committee this is this question of the
chair I see this is an FN I'm not sure
why I would understand that it's an
early Bill requiring a fiscal note
um not that you guys decide that I get
that but
um it's not real clear
um what this would impact in terms of
Department spending or state spending in
any way I'll look into the fiscal note
but so you know it's not been called out
as one of my early bills okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
England thank you very much thank you
everybody okay I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 537.
[Applause]
in one minute
okay being uh 11 22 I'm gonna open up
the public hearing and House Bill 386.
uh we held off for a few minutes waiting
for the prime sponsor who has not
arrived so as a courtesy rep chair
recognizes representative Hilt to
introduce the Bill thank you Mr chairman
and for the record I am representative
Greg Hill representing the town of
Northfield Merrimack II
um
I'm here to introduce House Bill 386 FN
a bill that lowers the age in which
child passenger must be retrained
I think it should be restrained
by a child restraint system
from ages seven to four
I
for all purposes I will not be taking
questions
thank you representative for introducing
she recognizes Thomas Leach from
Dartmouth Health in support of the bill
who is seeking 20 to 30 minutes to speak
and that's not going to happen
how about five
thank you for entertaining uh my my
presence here today my name is Thomas
Leach I work at Dartmouth health I am
the child passenger safety coordinator
for the State of New Hampshire which is
funded through a grant from the National
Highway Traffic Safety Office to our
local office of Highway Safety here in
New Hampshire
um New Hampshire has I thought I'd tell
you a little bit about the program so
you have an idea of where New Hampshire
sits with its current child passenger uh
safety record and so on New Hampshire
has a fairly robust child passenger
safety program we have
258 certified technicians and when I say
certified these are individuals that
have gone through a four-day class
that was designed through Nitsa and the
child passenger safety board in order to
kind of the Train the trainer type of
situation where these individuals most
of whom are either police fire Personnel
Hospital Personnel or
some type of family research Family
Resource
type of company here in the state that
either works through our health and
human services or others so we have
258 of these individuals and they work
out of 62 fitting stations and a fitting
station is a location that we advertise
on our website and other pamphlets and
media
to direct caregivers and parents where
they can go if they have questions
regarding their child seats
and these are very well received that's
done usually By Appointment sometimes
they'll have an event that many of you
might have been by Londonderry does an
annual one Dairy quite a few others will
do these things where parents can drive
in and have their seats inspected make
sure that they're following all the
guidelines and so on because they are
kind of complicated now those of you
that may have experience with child
seats for one reason or another probably
have been and frustrated when you go to
install it or harness a child in so it
is a complicated thing but New Hampshire
is doing very well we are closing the
gap on making sure that our most
vulnerable passengers are traveling as
safe and secure as possible through that
and it's showing where our injuries are
down our fatalities we haven't had any
in a couple years they're way down we do
we do like to talk about injuries more
though because those are the things that
stay with the child
possibly for the rest of their lives and
can also cost an exorbitant amount
amount of funding either through the
caregivers or through the state system
as well so we're very concerned about
injuries and that's what brings me here
today I'm very concerned about this bill
it would allow misuse as designed and
defined through the manufacture
bachelor's Association that produces
these child seats a lot of engineering
has gone in to this believe it or not
there's a there's a huge relationship
between NASCAR and other racing Sports
and child passenger safety a lot of the
same equipment is used it's just
downsized for a child size so we
wouldn't want to ask our NASCAR drivers
and other race car drivers to go back to
a three-point harness because they
wouldn't they've seen the advantages of
the systems they have in their cars
right now and those are the same systems
that we see in child seats the
engineering that has gone into them just
in the last 10 years is really quite
remarkable and the g-force is that these
seats can protect the child from it's
just amazing when they're used properly
and that's where I come in I try to gain
the proper use of these trial seats and
by proper use we refer back to the
manufacturer of these seats and it
usually goes to the point of wanting to
keep these children harnessed until they
maximize the weight and height of the
seats they're currently using so they
don't have to go out and buy any
additional seats or whatever they just
need to use them until the manufacturer
says he or she is too big for this seat
and they need to go to a seat belt which
is usually around the age of eight it
depends on the child as us in here we're
all different sizes whatever kids are no
different
so we try to stay away the industry the
child seed industry tries to stay away
from ages because ages are not
efficient they're not effective for
describing
the size of a child a four-year-old I
could bring five kids in here that are
four and they would all be extremely
different sizes I'm sure and that is a
problem one of the biggest problems if I
can go back and grab my my Hands-On
thing
the demonstration seat we used in our
training when we go all around the state
and we try and we hold these classes for
uh different individuals I spoke about
earlier uh whether it be fire police BMX
Hospital
and so on
this is supposed to be an average
three-year-old right we have these
training dolls across the switch to me
I have them at different sizes so that
our technicians in training have an idea
of how to Buckle in how to harness up a
child with that age maybe there's
restrictions on on
the type of seat they would be using
for example
a one-year-old would not be going into a
booster seat or something like that so
we really followed the guidelines of the
manufacturer so this is a three-year-old
average three-year-old she is bigger
than my
granddaughter which is three and a half
and she is much bigger and she's just a
teeny weeny I think she's weighing in a
so this is a three-year-old we didn't
have a four-year-old unfortunately but
this will show you some of the same
things that will still happen with
four-year-olds if that
they're not spinning properly and none
of us sit with our needs straight out if
we do
it's very uncomfortable so we manipulate
our body so that our legs can bend over
whatever couch chair and so on we're
sitting kids will do the same thing they
will scooch down so that they can get
more comfortable because we all want to
be more comfortable the way they do that
what happens is the black belt Rises up
over there ideally of you and I as well
we want that laptop over our pelvis
because above our pelvis our organs and
they're very susceptible to injury
from a laptop if there's no shoulder
problems
so this goes with the laptop to rise up
over the abdominal abdominal region a
lot of things in there that squishy and
gushy and can be injured very easily
and as you can see the shoulder belt
really does not fit well so what happens
with kids I see it even with teenage
small teenagers that struggle with the
seat belt system really different I know
people in here now what do they do they
put it under their arm or Mercy they'll
just put it behind the backs all right
so now we have a very danger for six
head trauma involverness in the
beginning of front seat depending on the
side seat because parents that
five-point Hearts I didn't bring a child
semen to me this
get the last one
but that five-point harness is the same
as NASCAR Jack fighter pilots use
and it's required
it moved up on its own based on
fatalities that have happened within a
racing industry and the child seat
industry
they take things from each other because
they're all paying Engineers a lot of
money the development sense to Institute
Works within a print and this projects
may become more vulnerable
and crash never mind the sign impact
issues
seen side impact issues or hurricane or
strengthening anything within the car
this is just her own body weight working
against her unfortunately
scissoring over and causing abdominal
Matrix
but instead of 27 years in law
enforcement and my specialty was
reconstructing fatal crashes and I have
prematurely and they've done that and it
almost always require some type of
Advanced Medical Assistance I even had
one
child
pick out several teeth with their own
feet that was that type of way actually
did survive for goodness but there's a
lot going on so the more we can restrain
these little guys uh and as long the
longer the better to them developmental
reasons another thing is kids don't
always talk about their injuries because
maybe they're not speaking yet or they
don't feel it yet and it's not until you
think about it but all of a sudden you
realize oh my goodness there's some type
of a long-term injury that's going to be
dealt with here through you know surgery
or
any type of extra therapy to go through
and so on and little guys shouldn't have
to be able to predict the weather or not
do something in school because of an
injury they sustained in a car
and they have to deal with
so that's pretty much
a shield for that if anybody have any
questions
if you can get back to our microphone
too please any questions from the
committee
representative Gorski
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
leech for taking my question this bill
talks about uh taking the restraint
stuff from being seven years old to four
years old
do you have any numbers or statistics in
terms of the number of injuries or
um that children have had between those
ages of like you know four to six I do I
wish I brought them with me there was a
a panel in in the um
um
the Senate that did a a pretty in-depth
research last year for the rear-facing
bill that's out there right now and
I'll speak mainly of New Hampshire
because that's what I deal with I wish I
brought the numbers with me we don't
have the best data collection in New
Hampshire so if that ever comes up that
uh there's there's a bill that wants to
create a better data system for New
Hampshire I'll come and I'll testify for
you too because it's it's really is
needed it makes us uh struggle with
trying to find answers like this
so I will look at EMS uh responses to
answer your question and we see a a
curve where our little guys are one two
or birth to two-year-olds caregivers are
doing a great job with them they're
they're really doing well with them
they're keeping them in very good seats
they seem to be surviving the most as
far as injuries go and as they get a
little older especially our
five-year-olds six through eight year
olds they suffer the most on New
Hampshire roads with injuries and again
it's the injuries that we really got to
cut back on because as little kids they
those injuries can last a long long time
so I hope that I hope that I didn't
bring the data with me uh it is
available through
um
I can email it to somebody if he was
just going to say if you could if you
could get that to us as a committee
that'd be great it's collected it's
collected from the crash reports that
are done uh via either the state police
system or the local system as well and I
actually get it from the um DMV
thank you sir any other questions from
the committee representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for coming
in and testifying
um
if I understand you correctly
uh
I'm you're you're against this bill but
would you
um suggest that
it may be more appropriate for our
current statute to list
um height and weight and all of those
kind of things rather than our current
statute that lists ages is that what I'm
hearing from you
that's a very good point and the reason
my understanding is the reason that ages
are used as much as they are in statutes
is for the enforcement part of it you're
not going to have an officer on the side
of the road with a scale or maybe a tape
measure and and there isn't a lot of
written enforcement that happens with
this law I know from my own personal
experience and I see it with the numbers
here in New Hampshire what this does is
it opens up an opportunity for a
roadside education where there could be
something that an officer sees is
definitely off and they can have that
conversation with the caregiver to
educate them on proper use because that
is the goal to modify people's behavior
and a lot of times that will happen
without any summonses being issued on
the side we have a lot of technicians
that are police officers and I know
speaking to them that is their goal is
that when Mom or Dad or the caregiver
leaves
um the the roadside traffic stop that
that child is safer than when they
originally stopped
um and so on but as far as excuse me
getting back to your question yes um
it all depends on the engineering that
has gone into these seats in the last 10
years is remarkable so on the side of
every seat is a very well laid out
labeling system that defines the size of
a child that should be in the seat and
how it should be used and that's what
the law also says on there that a
properly used child restraint according
to the seat manufacturers
and that's really the key right there to
do that whether or not an age is in
there it can help have that conversation
however in in my opinion it would be
great if New Hampshire had an age eight
uh or even nine with a size cut out
where we would want kids in seats until
age eight at least unless they were so
high and I'm sorry so heavy and so tall
which is part of of the original statute
anyway with the 57 inches
foreign
would you be able to provide us what
that cut out and those Heights and
weights and should be
as far as well you just mentioned that
they were uh you would prefer to have it
up to age eight with with cutouts and
and I'm wondering if you could provide
us what those cutouts should be it would
stay the same believe it or not because
that's the the cutout it's written in
the law now that says up to age seven
not not the bill but the current law
that we have and it says and children up
to age seven and up to 57 87 inches so
that would stay the same even though you
went to AJ because once a kid reaches 57
inches
that is
99 of the time acceptable to go into a
booster seat they would fit properly
into a booster seat at that time because
the problem with
seat belts and vehicles they're designed
for adults
and they're designed for different size
adults but they none of them go down low
enough to do a child properly so that's
why we want to keep kids at least in a
booster seat until
you know ideally under nine but again
have that exception that if it's a big
kid you know they don't have to stay in
the seat you know if they're 57 inches
then they should be in a booster seat
and if if they reach the maximum of
their booster seat then they can sit in
a seat belt
yep
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir for
is it not true that seat belts that are
put in cars today are in fact designed
for adults
further questions from the committee
representative sellers
bye
um
I'm just trying to figure out that
are you saying the parents aren't doing
a good job
uh protecting their children
because of the
you know because we want to drop the age
you don't think they go do a good job as
well
I think many will will continue to do
what they're doing now without a doubt
the problem is we have this conversation
um
you have a lot of issues going on with
with raising kids obviously and some
parents are more prepared than others
and others are reaching out to try to
figure out what it is and they may talk
to their next door neighbor they may
talk to a relative they may get their
initial child seat education maybe at
the hospital when they have a child a
lot of things happen though until that
kid gets to be four or five years old
there may be another introduction of a
sibling doesn't mean that the caregiver
cares any less about that five-year-old
or the four-year-old it just means
there's a lot more distraction now in
that family than just one child maybe
there's additional siblings all right
there may also be an issue with a
language barrier going on and this whole
idea is to keep that message consistent
our message in New Hampshire matches the
message in Vermont matches the message
in Massachusetts
in Maine in the rest of the country
all right so no matter where these
people look for their information
it's going to be consistent if we
deviate from that it's going to give a
mixed
um
message to the parents that oh okay
there is
a way to do this no parent is going to
deliberately put their kids in an unsafe
situation but we see it all the day
every day at our checkpoints where moms
and dads want to see that beautiful
little
14-month baby and they turn the kid
forward facing all right
um if if they can find someone just to
say oh yeah I did that then they feel
like they're they're not really doing
anything wrong and we're still combating
that message so we're trying to be as
consistent as ever so if we change the
message and we drop it down to four
you're right there's going to be some
parents that are going to do a fantastic
job but there's going to be a much
larger percentage that are going to get
the wrong message and they may be happy
with just tossing that kid in the front
seat of that car with a seat belt which
would be really bad because as
representative Sykes mentioned before
seat belts are designed for adults many
of you you may not even know it unless
you've had a crash in your car you have
in your front seat you probably had
pre-tensioners which are these small
little explosive devices that go off
that pull the seat belt tight and it's
not designed for a child to be sitting
in that we also have frontal airbags
which are very unsafe for kids they're
the ones that exist in in front of the
child all right so we want to keep kids
in the back seat we want to keep kids in
their child seats as long as possible
and this is the the guidance of the
American Academy of Pediatrics and I
don't know why anybody would want to go
against the Academy of Pediatrics when
we do take the time to bring our
children to the doctor we do take the
time to look after their well-being if
they get hurt we go to the hospital and
we listen so I I feel that transporting
children should be no different and we
should follow the guidelines of the
American Academy of Pediatrics
standards and that is to keep kids in
their seats as long as possible until
they outgrow them
foreign I hope that helped answer your
question what are the questions from the
committee
representative
Crawford
Mr chairman Mr Elise you you put on your
thank you you put on your pink card that
you support the bill I think you mean
you oh I apologize that was and I also
put the wrong build on because I was
looking at the I'm just talking with you
I am opposed to the to the bill moving
the the age to four years old I
apologize for that confusion
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so you're concern about changing the
law from from seven to four would send
kind of
people would interpret it as
confirmation that they don't need to put
their kids in a child seat that they
would use that as kind of a
uh
their Bellwether a rationality doesn't
require it so it can't be that important
I agree and also don't forget there
there is a little bit of a financial
responsibility to keep children in seats
because the progression these were
pieces of safety equipment and that's
just been noted by by so many of you
these are adult seat belts so they need
this specialized safety equipment to
make sure the seat belt works properly
for for them and I think if you said
after four you didn't need a child seat
which basically is is the underlying
tone of it
um you'll have parents go oh I'm done
with child seats now and they'll just
have the kids wherever in the car and I
think we would see
really see some horrific numbers in that
based on how far we've come seat belts
I'm sorry child seats really started to
take
a strong foothold not until the late
1990s
and they've been going great ever since
especially in the last 10 years like I
said the engineering that's gotten into
them and and the reality of it we've
learned from our children that and NASA
has proved this many times with how they
send astronauts into space when it comes
to being in a moving object we should
all be facing backwards I know I
wouldn't like it but if we want to
survive any type of serious crashes
that's what NASA says we should do so I
am afraid that the message would be
blurred
and and we would lose some people in
there that are struggling with
everything they're struggling with their
bills they're struggling with their
children they're struggling with with so
much going on that the last thing they
need is one more inconsistent message to
seeing no other questions thank you very
much thank you very much and I stand
corrected you got your 30 minutes after
all
chair recognizes
opposed to the bill
uh representing AAA Dan Goodman
welcome
thank you chairman members of the
committee uh I will be very brief uh for
the record my name is Dan Goodman I'm
the manager of public affairs for AAA
Northern New England uh to answer one of
the questions about uh car seats
um there's extreme misuse in New
Hampshire and across the country
regarding car seats according to data
collected by organizations like Tom and
uh and across country up to 50 between
52 84 percent of car seats across the
country are installed incorrectly and
the number one reason is they're in the
wrong misuse of the car seat so they're
in the wrong car seat for their age and
weight so it's a major major issue and
as I wear a post this bill we couldn't
find another state that has ever
attempted to do something like this to
repeal to weaken their child passenger
safety law New Hampshire would be the
first
um as Tom mentioned young kids are our
most vulnerable motor vehicle users it's
the number one reason car crashes are
the number one cause of death for
children between 3 and 14. we think
weakening those laws would just make it
worse
um as he mentioned the Academy of
American pediatricians recommended a
booster seat is recommended
typically to 8 to 12 years old or four
foot nine according to this bill Tom
wanted me to bring my daughter who's
almost four to be that to be that demo
instead of that little dummy she's
almost force transfer in a few weeks
she's three feet tall and 35 pounds so
according to the American Academy of
Pediatricians you know they're saying
four feet nine inches at least so uh
that's a very strong recommendation
um
um and we I did find a little data and
this is National Data by the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia uh children
seen in a booster seat in the rear of
the car are 45 less likely to be injured
in a car crash as compared to those
children using a seat belt alone
um so with that
um that is that is all I'm happy to
answer any questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
having no one else signed up to speak on
House Bill
our next bill will be Hospital 570 at 1
pm
thank you everybody enjoy a little
foreign
of
good afternoon everybody it's about uh
102 and I guess we will start the public
hearing on House Bill 570 relative to
real ID compliant New Hampshire driver's
license
and the chairman would like to recognize
representative Sykes and to introduce
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the transportation committee
um my name is representative George
Sykes Grafton 14 which is Ward 2 in the
city of Lebanon
um I'm pleased to introduce House Bill
570 which concerns language about
um real ID driver's licenses
um
we have been engaged in we meaning
myself and various
um
constituent groups have been engaged
with the Department of Motor Vehicles to
try and find uh common ground on what
this bill attempts to do to address and
so I want to talk about what we're
trying to do
what we're trying to do is bring
New Hampshire's real ID requirements
Interline with the federal real ID
requirements there's a slight disconnect
I view this as a
[Music]
um
attack that's not so much a technical
but maybe even it's not too far of a
stretch to say a housekeeping matter
that we're trying to bring those two
versions of the law into compliance with
each other
we've been engaged with the DMV for for
a great length and um
we have made some real progress but the
more progress needs to be done so what
I'm hoping to do is today is to give the
DMV and the constituent groups
um their opportunity to talk to you
about where we are what we're doing and
how it's going
with an eye toward
um
perhaps an amendment perhaps uh some
other parliamentary Maneuvers whatever
it is that we need to do to continue to
make good law here before the
transportation committee
and I'll take any questions if uh if
there are any
thank you very much any questions from
chair like to recognize uh jiel's
bassinet did I get that right
thank you uh from the ACLU who's in
support to Bill who is looking to speak
for one minute
thank you I'm sorry
you know I've done that many times so
you think I would know but uh
gilbissonet legal director at the ACLU
of New Hampshire we support this bill
um and just to Echo the the testimony of
the sponsor very briefly I I to some
extent really think this is a
housekeeping Bill maybe there are
administrative issues that need to be
sorted out but from a legal perspective
if this is a housekeeping Bill really
designed to make sure that state law
eligibility for a driver's license
matches real ID eligibility under
federal law that simple right now there
is a gap
between those who are eligible for real
IDs under federal law which is a little
bit more expansive and you look at state
law and it's narrower and so we're
trying to bridge that Gap and just to be
blunt that Gap exists with respect to
um not some non-citizens who are
lawfully in the United States I want to
be very clear that's who we're talking
about so under the federal real ID
statute and this is going to be in my
written testimony that I'll circulate
just so no one has to take notes but
under the federal real ID statute
um individuals who have approved Refugee
status individuals who have valid
non-immigrant visas Etc our intent are
entitled to have a federal real ID but
when you look at New Hampshire statute
with respect to non-citizens who are
lawfully in the United States that
criteria is much narrow right you're
dealing with
individuals who are attending school
you're dealing with individuals who are
here for the purposes of engaging in
lawful employment occupational business
activity and who are engaged in that
activity Etc but it's just a little bit
narrower in fact significantly narrower
than what federal law allows so we're
again we're just trying to bridge that
Gap to make sure that we're consistent
with the federal real ID statute and it
would have a real impact on individuals
who are lawfully in the United States
thank you
thank you very much any questions from
not seeing any thank you thank you Mr
chairman
and GEOS do you have written testimony
as well
I I noticed an error in my written
testimony so what I will do if it's okay
with you that I will email it to
everyone within the next hour after is
chair at this point I'd like to
recognize director marasco for the New
Hampshire DMV who's not taking any
position but it says information
testimony
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
my name is John marasco I'm the director
of The Division of Motor Vehicles I'm
here with Michael Mercier who is the
administrator of driver licensing at the
DMV I want to thank you for giving us
this opportunity to speak with you this
afternoon
um I'll start with echoing everything
that representative Sykes mentioned
about conversations that we've been
having with the representative and many
of the Great constituents and Community
leaders behind me and we've been talking
about a variety of bills this this is
one of them
um so what I would like to do is and the
reason that we're offering informational
testimony is to give you a little bit of
insight into some of those areas within
the bill and within the real ID act and
within the state law that we are
dissecting and trying to make sure that
we get to the right answer and make sure
that we offer you all the information
that you need to make the right decision
so if you look at
263 14b
New Hampshire RSA 26314b driver's
license compliant with public law
it talks about
um
that the department of safety May issue
May issue upon request driver's licenses
which meets the standards of the real ID
Act of 2005. so
that's the first start so we can do that
legally we can follow what's in the real
ID act and issue the real ID to all of
those parameters that are within the act
itself
so when you look at the real ID Act of
2005 and you go to special requirements
and you get to the section number two
special requirements be evidence of
lawful status
and then it goes into a state shell
require before issuing a driver's
license or identification card to a
person valid documentary evidence that
the person
one is a citizen or national of the
United States
two is an alien lawfully admitted for
permanent or temporary residents in the
United States three has conditional
permanent resonance status in the United
States
4 has an approved application for asylum
in the United States or has entered into
the United States in a refugee status
all of those that you go through you can
recognize has been approved uh has legal
status so those are all areas of the
real ID act you can look at and say well
that that makes sense we understand that
um one of the areas though that has been
a topic of conversation for uh for my
leadership team and the group here is
really
um section six Which states has a
pending application for asylum in the
United States so
when you get into the pending Asylum
status
the question then becomes what does that
mean
um and what does it mean when an
application is has been fully vetted by
the Department of Homeland Security to
make sure that the person receives the
full asylee status so
um
and part of the reason this is
informational testimony as well is that
as I said this is research and some of
that research was still taking place on
the way over here some of it took place
last week we had a conference call with
Amba the American Association of Motor
Vehicle administrators and a
representative from Homeland Security
for about 45 minutes and that
conversation centered around the real ID
act and in particular that's section six
what does that mean what does that mean
and so what was explained during that
call was that
um
unlike a refugee somebody who is in the
United States
goes and fills out the application for
Asylum they fill out that application
they submit that to the federal
government they get a receipt that
they've submitted that application
now during that call that we had last
week I was told that there was uh you
know it was just that a receipt that
you've submitted something
I was told on the way over from John
Mills who is uh the representative from
Homeland Security that um he did some
checking even within the last hour and
there is some level of vetting that
takes place when that initial
application is submitted so that's new
information
um so that's good what that level of
vetting is
he's going to get that information for
me but we don't have it as of right now
but it is more than just the receipt
which is what we were believing last
week there is some vetting that takes
place
the application is received and it takes
about 30 days for
the federal government to review the
application and to determine identity
so what happens is after about that 30
day Mark they can tell you that this
piece of paper that says John marasco
and here's his address and date of birth
all the information that's listed on the
application
is true and accurate
so that's a really good thing that's
good to know so at that 30 day Mark we
have true identity
as Homeland Security explained it that's
your first as they use the word touch
point the touch point is to figure out
now that you have a person's true
identity is that enough to issue a real
ID
well that's phase one of the process
through the federal government phase two
is the person is brought in for an
interview and the person undergoes a
background check and if they pass the
interview in the background check
then the process is essentially
completed
the person is eligible for
they've completed the process for a real
ID
um that can take although they wouldn't
give us an exact time frame that could
take potentially a year or more for the
the interview and the background check
to be completed
so
decisions that have to be made are
um
what happens if you issue the temporary
uh real ID to somebody that
um
got the receipt because they submitted
the application there's some level of
vetting that goes on there we don't to
this point know exactly what that is
um is that the time to issue the real ID
which is a higher level credential than
a regular New Hampshire driver's license
is it the right time to do it then is it
the right time to do it at the 30-day
Mark when you've got positive
identification with what's on the
application
or is it best to wait until the process
is played out albeit a long one and the
person has been properly identified they
have had an interview they have had a
federal background and they have been
approved to receive the real ID those
are some of the conversations that um
that we're working through and that
we've been having
I could tell you that the more that we
research this topic
um you know and I I think that what you
really need to do is have some attorneys
take a look at it for the state the
other thing is we have to stay in
compliance with the real ID act we have
to stay in compliance with it so I asked
John Mills from the federal government
on the way over here where we stand on
that if John Mills we're not doing
everything that's in the real ID act
today
because we're not
um are we in compliance with the real ID
act and he said we show up green on the
screen that we are in compliance with
the real ID act and that's where the
state law that says you may issue the
real ID
in these um for these certain uh
criteria you may do that but you may not
so the DMV has not been
um issuing real IDs generally speaking
for some of the categories that are on
here with the silees now somebody that
completes the process the administrative
rules for the DMV you you get once
you've completed the Asylum process you
you can get the real ID
you can you've had those three things
proper identification interview
background you you can get the New
Hampshire license
um
so those are some of the things that
we're we're working through
um and I think that uh you know we're
happy to take any questions I'll also
turn it over to Mike who oversees
licensing but these are some areas that
we are working through
Fair
does Mike want to say anything or before
I'm sorry no okay sorry for a second
okay there you go okay
um any questions from the committee
representative say clear
thank you Mr chair uh if you if the
state was to
issue the license after step two instead
of waiting another waiting a year up to
a year would it be impossible for if if
something was wrong to just revoke the
license like we do with drivers now in
sure
the only the only issue with that would
be how would we be notified if something
happened you know it had to be either
from the state department Department of
Homeland Security uh maybe a law
enforcement group we would have no way
to vet that if it went past it or before
the the to the Second Step that you're
talking about we can issue a license we
can issue a New Hampshire license it
just won't be a New Hampshire comp our
follow-up I may have missed something
but you you could I mean when when
somebody's licenses check on a road stop
they'll they'll run the license through
correct real ID or not so couldn't that
be done if uh or wouldn't that be done
if somebody shows a real ID that did it
temporarily and but this you guys
revoked it because they didn't pass the
third test wouldn't that be enough to
have that license taken away right there
on the spot
I'll
it would if it happened if if they ran
into a law enforcement officer but if
they were following all the laws and
everything was going along as normal we
would never know there'd be no way to to
know I mean we'd have to get a
notification from Homeland Security in
order to revoke that status
thank you
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
is there any do we have any information
of of
um what other states at what level of
this phase one phase two what other
states are issuing uh real ID at what
particular time and do they have this
this concern of issuing it those states
that have it
after phase one if someone fails phase
two and and the and the real ID is
issued which is I I think somewhat
representative Sinclair's question
what's the process that takes place in
order to
invalidate I would use the phrase that
real ID at that point
that's that's a great question
representative thank you um
so that that is part of the ongoing
research is to find out
um exactly what is taking place in other
states I did ask John Mills from um from
the federal government on the way over
here how many states are uh simply
have they migrated simply to the real ID
act and that's it whatever the real ID
act says they do
um he explained to me without giving me
an exact number that um it sounds like
the majority of states are doing that
they are going by what's in the real ID
act completely
um as far as those touch points go I did
ask those questions during the call that
we had uh where where is that
um and there really wasn't any strong
firm information on it one thing I
failed to mention during my testimony
was at the DMV we used the save database
run by Homeland Security and that's
something that can be queried to
identify is somebody have they after the
30 days and they've been uploaded into
the save database they've been
positively identified and we can see
that prior to that 30 days though
um you know you've got the receipt and
some level of vetting and my
understanding is they're not in a safe
database until that 30 day Mark so
you've got that that window there
um so I think part of our our
responsibility and a lot of a lot of
conversations have been had on a variety
of bills this one as well over the last
couple of months but I think there's
been more research done within the last
48 hours getting ready for this hearing
and dealing with a variety of bills to
make sure that we get it right that is a
piece that we have to continue on which
is what are other states doing and to
what extent what are they looking at for
touch points but it sounds like a lot of
them based on what he told me
um a lot are just adopting the real ID
Act
follow it
follow-up is part of that also the
procedure for
failure at any of those levels the the
revocation or is that is that part of
that you're also looking for yes I'd
like to know I'd like to know how many
states purely default to the real ID act
and then how many states operate in a
hybrid uh much like we do where there
are certain aspects of the real ID act
that they abide by and some maybe that
they don't and then what some states do
with regards to touch points is it that
once you file that application and
there's some level of vetting that takes
place at that time and you get a receipt
that your application's filed is that
enough thank you thank you
any other questions
representative C
thank you Mr chairman
um
my question is actually a two-part
question but first part is does New
Hampshire uh is New Hampshire able to
issue regular licenses without the real
ID function uh Canon does New Hampshire
do it
yes yeah I mean currently uh we're at
about 52 percent of the population that
has a real ID in New Hampshire so there
are still a lot of people in New
Hampshire that don't have the real ID of
course I didn't explain that the real ID
the benefit of it it's a higher level
credential that will allow you to travel
you know through an airport and also
into Federal buildings so
and that's why uh you know there's a few
more stipulations to the real follow-up
yeah
follow-up
um
for people seeking Asylum do they really
need to have the real ID function or
just an ordinary driver's license be
uh I guess it would be a preference but
the guarantee to have a credential here
in the state would be a driver's license
without the real ID attached to it
immediately they could always follow up
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um if that you issue a regular license
to them
and they fail the vetting process and
the Asylum request do you then have to
revoke the regular license as well or
so what would that be the same process
that
you would have to go through to revoke
the real ID yes so yeah the process
would be we'd get a notification back
from saves uh which tells us that they
haven't passed the the informational
background and we then revoke the
license
any other questions from the committee
representative Staub
thank you Mr chairman
if someone doesn't have a real ID are
they able to get on an airplane when
does that stipulation go into effect
that's a great question so that was just
pushed out it was supposed to have been
any other questions
with that I don't have any other pink
that was up there
up there the way up to hide up there all
right
the chair recognizes uh Eva Castillo who
supports the bill is looking for two
minutes
hello my name is Eva Castillo I'm a
resident of Manchester and I'm immigrant
rights Advocate and as an immigrant
myself as you can tell I may support of
this bill I think it's a no-nonsense
bill if the feds uh accept and license
people certain categories so people I
don't see why we cannot extend the same
courtesy in New Hampshire to the the
people that are extended real like these
under the the real ID act that's all I
have to say be made life easier for a
lot of people you know once it starts
acting out once it becomes mandatory how
people are going to be able to board
planes or do whatever if they are not
like
uh I'm a U.S citizen but all my
documents have different versions of my
name or combination so it's going to be
a nightmare so I got myself a US
passport card that's easy for me to
carry in my wallet but not you know
different immigrant categories are not
going to have that luxury so I think you
know he said No Nonsense low and I look
forward to keep working with DMV and and
figure out how we can make things happen
here in New Hampshire thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
cheer like to recognize Christine is it
well Wellman Wellington
who is supports the bill and
representing herself and asking for two
minutes
good afternoon chairman Walsh and
members of the committee I'm a resident
of Derry I'm also a member of the New
Hampshire immigrants rights Network and
I sent a letter last night by email to
all of you about our position on this
bill and I just want to make a few
points um attorney beesnet and Eva
Castillo covered many of the points one
one issue is that RSA
14-b is the statute that permits the
issue issuance of real ID level licenses
in New Hampshire if you read that Laura
as I did I read it to believe that it
only applied to that only U.S citizens
are entitled to that under the current
law so that's really the impetus for um
this legislation to allow the full list
of folks eligible under federal law to
be able to apply for driver's licenses
at the real ID level
the way we wrote it we put it into 263
39a which is the one statute that covers
nine U.S citizens and Licensing in that
body of Law and and it was really simply
put in a way that we believe gives the
DMV quite a bit of discretion in how
they carry this out it just simply adds
a clause that says that that um people
that are eligible under real ID are also
eligible for a real ID license so
um we're asking for that same
opportunity and to limit it right now
apparently to only U.S citizens or
within the discretion of the DMV really
limits equal opportunity and access and
that that you know is is a problem in
our opinion
we also
um think that because full compliance
with real ID is now may 2025 that means
that the state although they might be in
interim compliance may be out of
compliance on May 2025 if they don't
take actions to
um
open it up to the full Federal federally
mandated group of people and we think
that the way we
are presenting this this gives a DMV
plenty of time to deal with the minutia
in detail of how long you have to wait
before you get a license it may be
longer for people to have pending
applications it's something that's
already been approved so that the by
regulation the DMV could make processes
that they could live with and that would
be fair to the residents of the State of
New Hampshire and I think that's all I
have to say
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm not sure
um I listened to the organization that
you represent and I'm not sure I'm
asking the right question to the right
person but I thought I'd throw it out so
maybe uh director marasco could could
hear it as well and add it to his list
of questions
are you aware of any other country that
allows this level of
citizenship I'll call it
um or or scrutiny on their Drive is
um uh ID cards
um that would if some is there something
similar from Canada for instance or some
other that allows people pending
um hearings to have
um full or real ID type identification
are you aware of that I haven't really
studied other countries laws the only
remarks I'll make about it and probably
director marasco could be
more on point to your question I would
say that real ideas we all know is
enacted the whole big Act was enacted
after in the wake of 9 11 and it was to
make our country safer after this
terrible catastrophe and loss of life so
the feds have spent a lot of time
um working with this
director marasco mentioned that they use
the save program so that the State DMV
can tell if I say that I'm a legal
permanent resident and you run my info
through the system they'll be able to
verify that generally I mean there are
some mistakes in the system but
generally you're going to get an
accurate feedback that will confirm so I
think the state has done a quite a bit
to um to make sure that we're giving
licenses uh properly and with proper IDs
but this is based on federal law that's
lawmakers have spent a lot of time
um
betting and making secure so I I think
it's it's reliable and I think the
United States may have higher standards
than many other states I would think
Canada might have similar but they
didn't suffer what we suffered with 9
11. so I think that's the root of this
law
and yet they still recognize that
non-citizens are entitled to you know
equal access to a certain level of of
any other questions
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
I'm looking at the law here and it says
driver's license to a non-resident alien
who is living in New Hampshire on a
temporary basis
so you think that someone's only living
here temporary we should issue a real ID
well it's not it's not what I think it's
what the federal law says the that list
um is in it's I I have it attached to
the letter we sent and um I think Jill
will have it in his um his written
testimony as well
it has a list of who the federal
government says can get a federally
approved real ID license those are the
folks that they say are vetted to get
that I mean there's vetting that has to
be done at at the desk at the DMV but
those categories of people if you can
verify that I am who I say I am I am a
U.S citizen I am a temporary resident
but there's plenty of people that come
into the United States they may start
out temporary they may end up on the set
pass to citizenship they may be here to
study and and they'll leave but they can
get certain level of driver's license
and the list that we've I don't know if
anybody has a hard copy of of the the
letter I sent last night but the last
page of it has the list of everybody
that the U.S government says can get a
real ID level license now how you come
to that is what we left open to the DMV
what the processes they need to do to
satisfy themselves that they're issuing
to only people that are entitled to them
any other questions from the committee
chair and I would like to recognize
might have to help me with this viola
katsumi
representing herself who supports the
bill who's asking for one minute
thank you for the opportunity to speak
for the record my name is Viola katsume
and I'm here to speak on my personal
experience uh in 2020 when my driver's
license was up for Renewal
um I went to the
DMV website and looked up the again just
to make sure that I had the right
documents before I went to the office uh
and upon looking at the website I saw
information about real ID uh clicking on
that I got information about who
qualified in New Hampshire and it
referenced the federal requirements for
the real ID on that website so I opened
up the further requirements and
surprisingly I was among the people that
qualified for real ID
um so I called the DMV app and I said I
qualify for real ID what do I need to
bring and it was shortly told that I
didn't qualify because I wasn't a
citizen and so when I went to the DMV
office for Renewal I did inquire again
at the front desk to make sure that I
had the right information and I was told
the same thing um and I made sure to
cite the fact that the federal
government guidelines allow me to have a
real ID driver's license and I was told
the same thing that I had to be a
citizen to qualify in New Hampshire and
that doesn't really make sense I have
gone through that process I have been
varied I've been living here legally
working here contributing
um and I don't see a reason why I should
be excluded or other people like me and
I'm someone who travels for leisure but
also for work I don't want to be driving
around my past wherever I go and so I'm
just asking that this committee
considers that people that are here that
are legally vetted have gone through
that process already and one other thing
if you offered a driver's license it's
attached to your status so someone who's
still here temporarily for two years
their driver's license will be here for
two years maybe two years and three
months until
they check out of the country so they're
not here the the driver's license is not
here different from the time time that
your legal started the length of your
legal status bicycle is what I'm trying
to say so I hope that this committee
will consider that and so that again so
that we are the same we're treated
equally and also that New Hampshire has
the same law as the federal governments
why do we have to have two laws in the
state so thank you for your time and
please consider this bill
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
not seeing any thank you thank you
okay with that I now do not have any
more
pink cards so we're going to close the
hearing on HP 570.
our next bill we'll be talking up in a
thank you okay it's uh 140 here and I
guess we will start the public hearing
on HB 198
modifying the new Resident drivers
license transfer requirements
and uh the chair like to represent like
to recognize representative Tony lakis
who will be presenting the Bill thank
you for the record I'm representative
Tony lekkis representing uh Hillsboro
District 38 the towns of Hudson and
Litchfield and I'm standing in for the
prime sponsor who's stuck in his own
committee executing bills
so this is the same bill as HB 1643 that
was before this committee last year
and includes the amendment that was
considered by the committee at that time
after being sent to interim study this
committee voted to recommend it for
future legislation
this bill will amend RSA 263 colon 35
the section that requires new residents
to transfer their out-of-state driver's
licenses to an in-state driver's license
to add additional reporting requirements
if a person's circumstances change
within 60 days and direct the department
of safety to send reminder letters to
voters who presented out-of-state
driver's licenses at the polls if they
failed to do so so this bill is a
follow-up to the letter
that was sent back in September 6 2017
to then speaker
Jasper by the Secretary of State and the
commissioner of safety
in this letter they reported that dismal
84.5 percent unexplained non-compliance
rate with the driver's license transfer
requirements and that's
um you know their experience
and
um
representative Prout worked with the
Secretary of State assistant
commissioner Bailey and the DMV director
marasco and together they believe that
we have addressed that they've addressed
all the implementation concerns with
this bill
and um I passed out some written
testimony I believe that was also sent
electronically and I'll be glad to
answer any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair
thank you one question I may have missed
it in a testimony if somebody does leave
the state and they just re don't you
know do what they're being asked to do
what are the repercussions if any
um
I mean in effect there isn't much of any
I mean it it does say there's if they
leave the state within the 60 days
they're supposed to notify
um the DMV
um at least that provides an opportunity
that if they leave in that time
there can be a notification
um I suppose if they end up back in New
Hampshire and they're I mean really in
not seeing any thank you all right thank
you
she and I like to recognize uh Michael
Mercier from the New Hampshire DMV
who doesn't have any position on the
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Michael Mercier
I'm from the New Hampshire DMV and I'm
here to speak on behalf of house bill
198.
um
this bill kind of brings into question
what the representative was talking
about earlier
um
is it refined is there anything that
would happen to anybody who's going to
um
right now the DMV has no way of tracking
individuals either entering the state
unless they come to the DMV for a new
license or to register to vote and we
have no way of tracking if they leave
the state if they're here for that
specific time of the bill between the
first day and 60 days and they decide to
leave the state it's saying that they
have to notify the director
uh of their leaving the state
I
I moved to Florida I
I didn't notify the state that I was
leaving but they were notified that when
I applied for my Florida driver's
license
um that I established residency there
and they canceled my New Hampshire
license
there was no penalty at that point for
that so I don't I don't know who's going
to manage this I don't know how we're
going to set up a system to either track
people coming into the state or people
leaving the state and it's really all I
have to say I'm open to any questions
any questions from the committee
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question the process that you
went through when you went to Florida
um is that are you a uniform process
that would take place in all states or
is that just what Florida decided to do
or is how how is so that's that's
uniform throughout the states uh right
now the all the states are going through
What's called the state to state process
it's it's basically a one credential in
one state so anytime anybody moves to
Florida Nevada wherever they're going uh
if they go to register for a motor
vehicle or for a driver's license at
that point uh the state will send back
um electronic communications to the
state to state system and notify New
Hampshire that there's now uh Novell
license for the person that moved from
New Hampshire to Nevada that they've
canceled their New Hampshire license
a quick follow-up follow-up thank you
um is that strictly for
DMV or does that also get shared with
Secretary of State
so that's that's right now I know it's
strictly for DMV
um but there's a notification that the
DMV does uh every day at two o'clock in
the morning we send all the information
to the Department of State letting them
know
um the most recent uh residents are here
in the state of New Hampshire
thank you
representative Sinclair no
he did it for you
any other questions from the committee
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Mercier
um
did I understand you correctly that at
two o'clock every morning I guess you
meant two o'clock in the morning
that the DMV is sharing information with
the New Hampshire secretary of state
currently that's correct
how does the sharing of that follow-up
please follow up
how does this bill improve or negate
um
I guess as a current practice would be
it would negate it or improve it
it's just a notification that you know
we say for example we have 10 new 10 new
residents come in and register for their
driver's license
that gives their name address where they
currently are residing at and that'll
put them I guess with the whatever
District they're going to be voting in
so when they go to register to vote
they'll uh they'll have a
establish identity already here in New
Hampshire
representative C
uh thank you very much chairman uh the
question I have is
um does the Secretary of State provide
the DMV with information on people who
have registered to vote using an
out-of-state license and what do they do
with it that's a great question
unfortunately I don't know the answer to
that but I can definitely get that
answered to you when I found out from
the question I have is you you kind of
like asked a question like if this bill
passed
who's going to manage this I mean if if
that's the case I guess I'll throw it
back at you who
would manage this process
that's a great question I I don't know
who would manage that process I don't
know how we could establish a link
to inform us that somebody's moving into
the state without them doing any
official paperwork uh to register to
vote or register their vehicle I don't
and the other questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you thanks
okay with that I do not have any other
and we don't usually give second bites
yeah we usually don't give second bites
to the Apple
no no electronics Tony if you send
electronically we'll make sure the
committee gets it so with that I want to
all right welcome everybody
I'm going to open up the executive
session in Transportation uh on House
Bill 111. I am going to go not
necessarily well not in order uh House
Bill 111 establishing a committee to
steady electrical vehicle charging
stations for residential renters chair
recognizes representative representative
sellers for a motion
Mr chair motion it on this
great emotions itl is there a second
seconded by representative Hill
care to speak to motion
yeah I just don't think a committed a
study committee is necessary on this I
think the landlords will actually
eventually realize they need to put
charging stations at one point in time
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman
so
I know there's a lot of pushback about
study committees study commissions Etc
but you know what sometimes things
should be studied
um
there's a lot of what I'll call
misinformation out there about vehicle
charging infrastructure and how that
works and how it should work
and there's some
need in my mind to provide
opportunities for people to move into
apartment buildings and have be able to
bring their electric car with them I've
heard from several people uh
who are needing to move because their
apartment their old apartment building
is being the rent's going up so much
that they can't afford to live there so
they're trying to move to another place
and they want to bring their electric
vehicle with them but there is no
infrastructure in the in many of the
places that
they look at so a study committee to get
down to the correct details about
electric vehicle infrastructure
um I think is prudent more and more
people are living in apartments uh
particularly younger generation if you
talk to
um people who study the demographics of
our state
those people who are moving in are
generally young professional don't
particularly want to own a house would
prefer to rent they want to minimize
their environmental impact by owning an
electric vehicle and so why are we
putting roadblocks in their way why not
understand that a commission could
examine all of these issues from the
lens of what are we doing as we move
forward as opposed to
some bad information that's out there so
I would urge the committee to vote
anybody else in the committee
representative Sinclair
thank you I I agree with representative
sellers comments about the market and
and whatnot but at the same time I I
don't see where a study committee would
hurt on this because maybe through such
a committee there would be availability
made to landlords and stuff to see how
they could do this and and and
I hate to use the word educate them but
you know just show them the way that
this would be a good thing for them and
maybe there's some funding or grants out
there that would help them uh with any
added costs for this so that's all thank
you
representative sellers
I wasn't really going to speak more on
this but uh it just that will happen my
son actually lives down in New York City
and he was actually working for a
landlord who owned a thousand apartments
and he was actually uh putting in
charging stations so they're they're
realizing they need to be done it's just
take them a little bit longer to do it
so
thank you sir anybody else
see you then I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll when she's ready the motion is
Ito on House Bill 111.
representative Smith
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Hill yes
representative Dumas yes
representative Barry yes representative
Ankerberg yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Sykes no
representative rich
representative Sinclair
no representative Fox
no representative Rambo no
Representative vayu no representative
Coker yes
representative Jones no
representative Holland no
representative Saab
stop
no sorry
and chairman Walsh
yes
11 9.
okay our committee recommendation of itl
is adopted 11-9
I'll get a few minutes to reset we'll
okay next up
uh we will exec House Bill 132 relative
to Tire disclosure for resale of
trailers by utility dealers chair
recognizes representative Hill
uh yes Mr chair thank you I would uh
I would move itl on House Bill 132.
seconded by representative Gorski would
you care to speak to your emotion
uh certainly Mr chair
um
while I have sympathy for the uh the
sponsors and their troubles on the
roadside with a with a used tire they
bought from a used trailer I'm not sure
their solution of a
um
of a disclosure from the dealer is the
is the appropriate solution
um I already there's a number of forms
and papers that get passed with buying
used vehicles but I would suspect
um it it might be better to just have a
uh an independence inspection whenever
you buy anything used including Tires
and Brakes so that would be my
suggestion and uh for that reason I
suggest an itl on House Bill 132.
thank you anybody else from the
committee
representative Sinclair
I just want to I I asked representative
Hill about
a couple of things and one one idea I
had which I think I mentioned the day of
testimony was to have manufacturers put
not just the code but the actual date
that the tires were were made and uh he
pointed out to me that that would be
kind of tough to do
in this room to get to make
manufacturers do that
so I I have to agree with them about
um
that the buyers need to uh
show enough you know
to have people check out the not only
the person that's selling it or the
dealership but maybe have that
independent uh person
look at the vehicle or the trailer and
to help them out
thank you
thank you for that and in terms of the
tires according to my written my notes
written down the tires already do have a
date on them it's not it's not a month
day and year but it's week in year so I
mean the information is already on the
tires anybody else from the committee
representative Sykes
um I too have great Sympathy for the
representatives and their Misfortune
relative to their uh
purchase however I'm oftentimes and in
this case particularly uh reluctant to
make law based on what at this point has
presented to us as a one-off
type situation now there probably are
other examples but no testimony led us
to to learn that so I I'm I will be
reluctantly voting for the motion
anybody else
seeing nana'll ask the clerk to call the
roll and she's ready uh motion is itl on
House Bill 132.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Berry yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
rich
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox
yes representative Rambo yes
representative yes representative Coker
yes representative Jones
representative Howland yes
representative stubb yes
and chairman Walsh
yes
20-0
committee's recommendation of itl is
who was that
representative moves consent any
objections
seeing none consent that is closed the
exact session on House Bill 132.
they stand corrected uh we will not be
taking up house was Bill 153 next we
actually have two amendments on it and
it's agreed that I think we can probably
make a third one that solves everything
so I'll reschedule house bill 153.
um so next up we will be taking house
oh and then the Spaceport
space was not gonna send it I love that
they use the starfish
okay next step we'll open the executive
session on House Bill 163 FN relative to
authorized license plate decals
Jay recognizes representative sellers
for a motion
Mr chair I motion this ought to pass
who was that I said come up I saw
representative Rambo uh would you care
to speak to motion sure basically Mr
chair this is just a a housekeeping
adding in space force and a few other
medals that were um
that veterans actually that earn the
medals can actually apply for to have
that decal uh after talking to the I
believe it was the agent General there
the cost of this over a long period of
time is going to be very very minimal
just because
some Bedford some veterans very prideful
and they won't get the detail and others
that will actually want it a firearm a
thank you sir anybody else
representative Jones
just a question for you Mr chairman uh
with this motion is our lines 21 through
29 now emitted
no it's moved unchanged no amendments to
remove those 21-29 we would need an
amendment to do so so it's moving on and
it's this motion moves it on in its
original form thank you
anybody else
seeing them I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion is ought to pass on
House Bill 163.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
yes representative Smith yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative Dumas
representative Barry yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
rich
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Ayo yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative Holland yes
representative Staub yes chairman Walsh
yes 20-0
our committee recommendation about the
pass is adopted 20-0
is there a motion for consent consent
moved by representative Gorski any
objections
seen on consent that is I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 163.
Mr chairman
got a quick question um if I want to
make a motion to reconsider a pass bill
can I do that now or
you can but it may be a different
opportunity if you want to plow through
all these okay and
um
yeah let's do these and at the end I'll
recognize it
you do have an amendment that's being
offered so I'll hand those out before I
okay
okay so I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 268fn
relative to the Furnishing of special
number plates to The Liquor Commission
division of enforcement and Licensing
chair recognized representative Smith
with a motion
sure somebody okay um motion's been out
to pass how's your second sure I'm
seconded by representative Hill
representative
Smith
thank you Mr chair I move Amendment 2023
-0365 h
uh oh second and that's seconded by
representative Hill also uh would you
care to speak to your Amendment
thank you Mr chair and the past session
or two we fielded a request to give the
clerk of the house a cover plate like we
have and since he is also like us an
elected official of the general court we
saw no reason not to honor that request
to pass this committee passed the house
died in the senate for some reason
taking another swing at it
um yeah so uh Paul is a dedicated
member of the general court and if you
want to know how much he loves the house
and you have a spare couple of hours
so uh this is harmless costs nothing and
I hope my colleagues can support the
amendment
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
seeing none
um I'll just
representative C
does this amendment eliminate the plates
for the Liquor Commission
no if you look at the way it's written
it says amend the bill by inserting it
to section one the following and
renumbering the original section two to
read is three so structurally the way it
works is everything that's currently in
the bill stays and it's just added to it
with a renumbering
does the amendment need to be seconded
uh we're going to vote on in a minute I
was just answering that question okay
I've already got the second
so with no other questions all those in
favor of adopting Amendment uh zero
three six five H say aye
aye opposed name
hearing none the amendment's adopted our
motion is now ought to pass as amended
on House Bill 268 any further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
Vice chairman Gorski yes representative
Smith yes clerk votes yes representative
Hill yes representative Dumas
representative Barry yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative vayu yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative Holland yes
representative Stout yes and chairman
Walsh yes
20-0
so our committee's recommendation is
adopted 20-0 is there a motion for
consent
who was at Saint representative Saint
Claire's and yet without objection
consent it is
okay I'll close the executive session on
House Bill 268. next up
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 374 FN relative to the
application process for driver's
licenses and the privacy of Motor
Vehicle records chair recognizes
representative Gorski for a motion thank
you Mr chair I I motioned uh itl for HB
374.
Ed by representative Hill would you care
to speak to motion representative Gorski
I do
um Mr chairman just uh reading a bill
and listening to testimony
one of the first things I I have I
wrestle with is the first hurdle which
is
um someone who is illegal in this
country getting access to a driver's
license I view a driver's license as a
privilege which should be for legal
citizens
the other issue I have with the bill is
the whole thing about privacy that in
fact if someone does get
um you know stopped or
in some way have to show ID if in fact
they are shown to be here illegally
we're not allowed to share their
information we have enough for people
here in a state that we don't really
know how many people we have
um so I that are here illegally So based
on all that I have
um an issue with this bill and that's
why I recommend itl
thank you anybody else from the
committee
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman
somehow someway this Bill gets tagged
with a lot of things that it isn't and a
lot of things that it is get lost
and I want to try and refocus
everybody's attention on the fact that
that the first and foremost this is a
bill about Public Safety
and I say that because
in now 20 jurisdictions throughout the
United States
um a version of this bill has passed a
version of this bill has gone to a a
vote by the public to either deny or
approve such a bill and the public
overwhelmingly voted in favor of this
bill in past testimonies before this
committee
the chiefs of police and specific police
Chiefs had suggested that this was a
good tool for police departments and the
reason for that for them saying that is
they want in their very best efforts to
make connections with all members of
their community
it's called community policing
this will help them make connections
with a segment of the population that
whether we want to acknowledge it or not
those folks are living here in New
Hampshire
the total numbers unknown probably
somewhere is around 15 000 people
those folks are
living here
paying taxes
they are providing for their families
and in a state that is as challenged as
this one in terms of public
transportation
they end up sadly driving anyways
or from my money I would much rather
have a person
have a legal route to
take a written exam
take a
practical exam
and demonstrate several very important
points not least of which is that they
can actually drive and know how to drive
and on top of that it will also help
identify who they are where they live
those are important considerations in
our fluid Society now
will
um
help
us get to a a place where the people who
are here anyways
can fit in better
not doing this is not going to cause
those persons to go away they're still
going to be here
not doing this is not going to fix any
problems and I'm just going to tell the
story I've told it before and I'm going
to tell it again
when asked by my wife to her grandfather
what he did for a living he was a state
senator
he said well I listen to people's
problems and I try and fix them
well I think that's incumbent upon us as
well I think every one of us here can
agree that the immigration system in
this country is broken
it's not doing what it should do
but we have an obligation as
representatives to tackle those
difficult issues
that are given to us to be responsible
for driver's licensure is not a federal
issue it is a state issue we should be
tackling this trying to make
our state our families and other folks
as well safer because we have
demonstrated that they are who they are
who they live where they say they live
and they are
been tested to prove that they can drive
on top of that it will give them the
opportunity to register a car and get
insurance which is also very important
piece of this as well I think it is a
disservice to folks who would not be
eligible for this license to not support
this bill and I I think that's I just I
just
ask that you open your hearts and look
to to to try and help
everyone in this state and the best
thank you representative for anybody
else from the committee representative
Sinclair thank you I just like the fact
that that this bill uh
would make my life a little safer on the
highways by having more people that are
out there
probably have taken a driver's test and
hopefully know what they're doing and as
as the last speaker said well more
likely have insurance which will help me
if I get in an accident with them thank
you
anybody else from the committee
representative Jones
thank you Mr chair
um
as we all know driving isn't our right
it's a privilege and it's a privilege
that has to be earned
and I think
we're better off having people out there
on the roads who have earned the
privilege to be there for safety reasons
Alone
um
I know uh
deaths and accidents and pedestrian
deaths are all up in in New Hampshire
and this is another way to help make it
safer
so I'm I'm going to be a
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
I I get we want everybody to have a
license I get that but when you start
looking at the bill and you say
okay the state police can have the
information the sheriffs can have the
information
the Town Police can have the information
but the immigrations can't have the
information that's in the law they're
saying they can't have the information
the the other area in here too that that
kind of points out to me is um
let me just find it for one second
um
is that for whatever reason I'm not sure
why
but the person that's applying for the
license can also opt out as far as
giving a Social Security number so they
don't have to have a Social Security
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
so uh somebody stole my thunder about
the uh the privilege but it's worth
pointing out insurance is not required
in New Hampshire
and I don't know if anyone has done some
sort of statistical analysis of how many
of these folks will go out and get the
insurance because they're not required
to
the safety argument so this bill's been
a frequent flyer and I recall in past
testimony hearing the lengths the folks
go through because they're afraid of
being pulled over
walk arounds on their car making sure
that all the equipment is correct and
working there was one gentleman a few
years ago who even testified that he
installed a mirror on a back wall of his
garage so we could make sure his lights
on the back of the car were working
before he left
you know what I did this morning
while drinking coffee at my kitchen
table I remote started my car and
eventually went outside made sure the
tires weren't flat and I drove it two
hours here
who was safer so the safety argument I
I don't know how you would prove it
either way but from the past testimony
we've had on these bills they're far
safer than I was today so I just I don't
anybody else from the committee
representative Sykes
okay I'll representative okay
um thank you Mr chairman
um
the the part about
not sharing with immigration makes sense
to me because it would defeat the entire
purpose of the bill because nobody who
has who who would be afraid of having
their information reported to
immigration would want to get a license
because and then you defeat the entire
purpose of the you know the safety part
of it
um you you defeat the purpose of law
allowing law enforcement to have a valid
identification of a person that they can
look up in their system if they're
looking for somebody or trying to
identify them on the side of the road
they'd be afraid of stopping at an
accident still because they would be
afraid that their immigration status
would be uh questioned during the during
the stop so it doesn't add anything to
safety to to have this information
shared with immigration because then it
would deter people that we're trying to
get to get licenses
from getting licenses so that's
um
that's what I have
thank you sir representative Sykes
yeah I know that one of the things I
forgot to mention
um
specifically talking about
data from Connecticut Connecticut by the
way is one of the many states that have
passed a similar Bill Connecticut has
Massachusetts has Rhode Island has
Vermont has New York has see a pattern
more importantly though in Connecticut
when they passed a similar Bill like
this
the next year their data for hit and run
motor vehicle crashes went down
significantly
and the belief was that it's because
undocumented persons who now had
driver's licenses were staying instead
of fleeing
anybody else
I just want to add this I guess because
I've seen this bill three times now I
think and it just doesn't
make sense to me I think it's backwards
now I know we just retained House Bill
650 which is trying to remove the
privilege of driving
um the suspension of your license for
not paying other fines and CR and
committing other crimes but right now
currently in statute you can have your
license taken away for a myriad of
things and there's even a bill going
through the Senate right now that's
going to include paying your fish and
game uh rescue fees uh it's another
reason you can lose your license so our
current laws across the book say that
the privilege of driving is fair game if
you break our laws now at our public
hearings over and over and over I keep
hearing some people saying that well
that they possibly broke a law to get
here they're currently breaking the law
right now because they're driving anyway
in spite of the fact that they're not
supposed to if they don't have a Social
Security number I have to assume that
they're working illegally so I don't
know how you can say you can look at one
set of it and say we're going to take
your privilege but for these particular
lives we're going to give you that
privilege makes no sense to me I'll be
supporting the itl
uh I'll ask the clerk to call the rule
when she's ready
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes yes representative Barry yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
no representative rich
representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative
Rambo no Representative vayu no
representative Coker yes
representative Jones no
representative Holland
no representative Staub no and chairman
Walsh
yes
say 11 to 9.
all right our committee recommendation
of itl is adopted 11-9
so it'll close the executive session on
House Bill 374
okay
would open up the executive session on
House Bill 375 relative to the licensure
of non-resident aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire chair
recognizes representative gorsky for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I motion to itl HB
375. motions in expedient to legislators
there a second
by representative Hill
would you care to speak to your motion
sir I would thank you Mr chairman
um
HP 375
um when testimony we had um
some information shared about
a
Asylum Seeker who was having some
difficulties in regards to
getting a license and although I can
sympathize with that story that was
provided to us in testimony one of the
things that still troubled me
is that right now
putting down Asylum status tends to be
kind of the default statement anybody
who's coming in over the Border
I would agree that there are some who
are definitely looking to get Asylum who
are legitimate but we have far too many
who fall in that category of falling
into Asylum Seekers and with that and
with the current immigration in status
at the border I just cannot support this
particular Bill and that's why I am
voting to uh for itl
representative Sykes
so
as I explained in the public hearing
that there was there are folks who
legitimately seeking to enter the United
States uh they get here legally they
apply for Asylum status
they again legally
they are told that if they live in New
Hampshire they must get a driver's
license after 60 days and then in the
very next breath they're told that they
can't because they do not fulfill all
the requirements
um
one of which is to have either a work
permit
now
hearings for legitimate Asylum Seekers
are years in the waiting
the good news is that
even the federal government recognizes
there's a problem there so
how does one who is here legitimately
how does one provide for their family
well the feds say well after
365 days if you
have not had your hearing for Asylum
then we will give you a work permit
and then once you are in possession of
that work permit you can go back to the
DMV
and up
take the test both the practice the
written and the Practical exam and get
your driver's license this bill is
nothing more than trying to close the
gap
between when a person arrives when
they're told they must get a driver's
license and when they can actually get a
driver's license
I hear
false complaining about all those quote
unquote all those people who are coming
into the United States and they're it's
just a matter of form they apply for
Asylum well I don't know where that data
came from but
um
I worry that we are punishing people who
are trying to say in many cases save
their lives save the lives of their
family we get up and we have moments of
silence for us people who are coming
here to the United States from places
like Ukraine and other countries where
there's absolutely devastating
conditions going on and those folks are
legitimately applying for Asylum and yet
they cannot
obtain one of the more necessary items
here in in this state because of the
lack of public transportation
I'm just going to say it again and I'm
no some may feel that I'm being a broken
record but this is the right thing to do
and it's something that we
ought to do and we're trying to get the
language
perfect as we can
[Music]
so I would urge my colleagues to vote in
favor of this bill so that we can help
the people who have come here under very
difficult circumstances and who are
I agree with you representative Sykes I
think
I think we are punishing well not us but
I think the federal government's
ignorant ignoring of the federal
immigration laws is punishing a lot of
legitimate asylees
um and but the statistics you seek in
terms of the percentages of people that
are just claiming Asylum because it's
because they're seeking a better life uh
not not not fleeing from religious
persecution or Wars Etc is out there and
I will provide it to you anybody else
from the committee representative Hill
thank you Mr chair
um my only comment is and I've and I've
done the research and I have come up
blank
um if anyone could enlighten me any
country in the world that would um
allow something similar
if if I was to cross their border and
seek Asylum that I would be able to have
driving privileges I I'd very much like
anybody else from the committee
representative sellers
so again I'm going back to the written
part of this where where they're asking
for
it says who has filed a complete
application
for Asylum I don't even I haven't seen a
complete application I don't even know
what what's on there for one so that
would make it very hard for me to make a
decision like that and of course that's
what the United States Senator
citizenship and the immigration service
so one moment we want to use the
immigration service the next one we
don't want to let them know anything
and also on this it says written
acknowledgment of receipt well what is a
written acknowledgment is that me just
saying yeah okay you got a receipt I
mean it doesn't there's not enough in
here and then the third part of this
it's only good for 180 days and I
thought there was a further Gap I
thought they said that there could be
seven or eight month Gap here so it
might not cover everything even as it's
written
anybody else in the committee
representative Coker
I share representative sellers concerns
about the um the question I have in the
language and that's when it actually
with a testimony for the real ID
um it got brought up with a DMV
um you know the question I have is that
just to fill that application and the
receipt that it has it's kind of like
okay so they they filled an application
and they just get the receipt but it
seems like there's different phases so
um I don't know if I would vote to itl
it but yeah I'd rather retain it but
that's just my I'd like to get that
answered if anybody knows off the top of
anybody
I don't have the answer for you either
anybody else from the committee
seeing none
um
I'll ask the clerk to call the role
whenever she's ready
okay the motion is itl and house bill
375.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Barry yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Sykes
no representative rich
representative Sinclair no
representative Fox
no representative Rambo no
Representative no representative Coker
no representative Jones no
representative Holland no representative
Stout no chairman wall
yes
10 to 10.
okay so 10 10 the motion of Ito fails
chair recognizes representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion of
ought to pass
second
it was moved to ought to pass who
seconded that representative Jones any
see did you yeah just briefly I'm
okay representative Sykes would you care
to speak to your motion I I would Mr
chairman thank you I would just point
out that many other states uh including
some that would surprise you for example
Texas allows Asylum Seekers to get a
driver's license we do not prohibit
Asylum Seekers from getting a driver's
license here in New Hampshire we in fact
allow it it's just a question of when
and so this is really just a technical
fix to close that Gap and I would urge
the committee members to vote in favor
in simple terms for me
the the process of seeking Asylum
it is a process and and what this bill
seeks to do is to give a privilege from
the state of New Hampshire for its
driving privileges before that process
is complete again kite before the horse
in my opinion I'll be supporting the
uh no I'll be opposed to the ought to
pass
no no so uh I'll ask a chair to call the
role I mean yeah to call the role when
she's ready uh the motion we're acting
representative Hill no representative
Dumas representative Barry no
representative Ankerberg no
representative C no representative
sellers
now representative Sykes yes
representative Rich representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
yes representative Coker yes
representative Jones yes representative
Holland yes representative Stout yes
chairman Walsh
no
10 to 10.
okay
Mr chair I have a question
yeah go ahead representative
would it be possible to make a motion
that's that's in order
I'd like to make a motion to retain the
bill representative Saint Claire moves
retain on House Bill
sure I'll second
by representative Smith would you care
I didn't realize I'd have to do that I I
just think I think you know we've had
two votes uh 10 to 10 and I think this
bill uh we can maybe work on it just a
oop representative Smith
so I have a lot of questions for such a
small short bill so for example
the written acknowledgment of receipt
so I just looked up on Asylum Seeker
advocacy project you can apply online
and get this digital thing is this that
does it indicate that your application
is complete because the bill says it has
to be and I'm not sure that the receipt
provides that so I don't know retain is
an opportunity to get answers to the all
the information missing from the bill
he ain't none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll motion on the floor is to
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill sure yes
representative Dumas
representative Barry yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative C yes
representative sellers
yes representative Sykes no
representative rich
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox
no representative Rambo
no
representative
representative Coker yes representative
Jones
yes representative Holland no
representative Style no chairman Walsh
yes
13-7 13.
yep
all right the committee vote of 13-7
retained uh to retain house bill 375.
I'll close the executive session on
House Bill 375.
Mr chairman I'd like to make a motion
which stage of motion uh reconsider
House Bill 646
uh there's been there's a motion to
reconsider House Bill 646 it is in order
and it is allowed I still have
possession no no reports have been sent
in is and as for everybody that's
backtracking this is uh eliminating the
vehicle inspection mandate for
non-fomercial vehicles is there a second
I'll second that that's seconded by
um before we go into discussion War
the vote I'm going to recess our
executive session till 3 15. is that
320. so I'm going to recess the
executive session on House Bill 646
yeah we got everybody in here too so oh
six four six
that's the inspection bill
okay
I like mundane
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna re uh reopen the
executive session on House Bill 646 FN
uh where we stand now there's a motion
to reconsider on the floor it has been
seconded
did you care to speak to emotion on the
reconsideration
so I just think out of all the issues
that I hear back from the constituents
and it maybe I've just got a weird
District but people are unhappy with
inspections uh you know and I get that
we need them I I believe we need them
for safety purposes but the system I
mean since I I moved up here from
Florida about 10 years ago and when I
got to New Hampshire to live for your
die State I was kind of shocked that we
had to do yearly inspections and not
only that but the you know
it there's it's it's just it's a broken
system there's there's there's all kinds
of you know I mean just there's so many
stories about going to one shop and
getting you know one story going to
another shopping in a different story I
mean this it needs to be fixed and I
think by keeping the spill alive and uh
retaining it afterwards it's gonna give
us some time to look and see if we can
actually do something for it
anybody else from the committee
thank you Mr chairman so
um
I'm going to vote against
reconsideration and the reason for that
is because the strength of the work that
we do
and the public nature of our work where
we publicly notice bills that we're
going to vote on and how we're going to
hear testimony on is never a surprise to
anybody
I think we voted one way and now we're
going to vote again how many times are
we going to be voting on bills again and
again and again
negating the possibility for those
important stakeholders to be present for
the arguments the discussions and so on
where they can participate whereas if
today they won't have that option so I
will vote against reconsideration that
does not mean that I won't
take under advisement the any subsequent
motions I certainly will but for the
well representative Smith
thank you Mr chair those stakeholders
already participated during the public
hearing and were an executive session
now as we were the last time we voted on
the bill and they do not get to
participate in executive sessions that's
what we debate amongst them ourselves so
I'd reject that argument if the bill
does go to Rattan there will be work
sessions and all those stakeholders can
participate and that's actually My Hope
because you're not in a weird District
as a matter of fact after I'd chaired
this committee for four years I became
like DMV guy yay and got complaints from
all over the state the system is broken
one of the largest problems that I hope
the committee could address because it's
our fault is we passed the law and then
put a 541a clause that says the
department can create rules
and like that's the end of our
involvement we already had one incident
with um rust failures so you you
shouldn't have to have a pretty car
in order to pass an inspection and this
committee recognized that so instead we
took the rust qualifications and put
them in the statute so that it was no
longer open to interpretation by the
department or rules or anything
unfortunately we believe a lot of
stations even though that was years ago
still don't have that information
so technically when they fail a car for
rust that's cosmetic they're violating
the law but they're following the rules
I'd like an opportunity to work on that
problem and figure out how this
committee which has jurisdiction over
this issue gets control of the process
again so that we have an answer for our
constituents when they come to us thank
you Mr chair
anybody else
and I'll just add this to representative
sakes I mean parliamentary speaking we
still have possession of this bill as a
committee so reconsideration vote is
appropriate because people do change
their mind while we still have
possession of it I'm one of them I voted
for the itl two weeks ago or last week
whenever it was and it dawned on me
after the fact I've been defending this
program for 10 years
uh taking my lumps in the process but
also aware that it's been broken for
years and it's nobody's fault that these
things don't get addressed uh it's a
large problem it needs to be looked at
as such and with an Ito I know it's
going to happen nothing is going to
happen by retaining it which I hope is a
subsequent motion we can really really
look at this thing and try to resolve
some of the issues that our citizens
have with this program if we can't it'll
be the last time I defend it but right
now this is a legitimate effort to get
into the weeds so I'll be supporting the
motion to reconsider and then we'll go
from there anybody else from the
committee
if we retain this then would it uh end
up on the Calendar's working session on
Bill number something or other or how
would that show up
so so what happens first we have to
adopt or pass
uh reconsideration in the committee once
reconsideration if it passes then the
motion on the floor here will be the itl
that we Pat voted on last week
if we want to move any further with a
retain option then the itl will have to
be voted down if the itl is voted down
then a subsequent motion of retain can
be made so if we get to retain there
will be nothing in the calendar on it
and then it'll be just once we get
through our house business and in May or
June or whether whenever the speaker
allows to start working on retained
with no other questions I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll the motion is on
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes for the clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Dumas yes representative
Berry yes representative Ankerberg yes
representative C yes representative
no representative rich
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox
no representative Rambo no
Representative no representative Coker
yes representative Jones no
representative Holland no representative
Stout no
chairman Walsh yes
Mr chairman I have a question if I may
um
does a reconsideration motion on the
floor of the house has to be made by the
prevailing side was that does that rule
apply here too in committee
I don't know that's why I'm asking I do
not believe so okay
but I believe in this case it was and
just to become yeah I'm just I'm trying
to learn too yeah
who made the motion to reconsider and
seconded representative
I don't know he was not a good deal
he voted for the oh that's true well no
I had a conversation with the clerk I
don't believe in committee has to be a
member from the prevailing side but I
can double check with Steve yeah who's
I was even
we're working on it
I was even going to suggest it could be
for subsequently well it wasn't going to
change anything about this
okay
all right
okay so the motion of reconsideration
um is adopted 12 to 8. so that brings us
to the
this current motion of itl so as I
mentioned before the motion on the floor
is Ito we have to vote on this one more
time if you want to move to any other
motion do we have to you will vote no
against the Ito if you want to leave the
Ito obviously you're going to vote Yes
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the rule
on
Vice chairman Gorski no
Vice chair excuse me representative
Smith no
work votes no representative Hill no
representative Dumas no representative
Barry no representative Ankerberg no
representative C no representative
sellers no representative Sykes yes
representative rich
representative Sinclair no
representative Fox yes representative
rombo yes representative yes
representative Coker no representative
Jones yes representative Howland
yes
representative Staub yes chairman Walsh
um no
just confusing myself here I just want
to be careful all right so
um
okay so the motion of itl on 646 fails
eight to twelve
is
is there a motion I'd like to make a
motion
go ahead to retain 646
uh retain on 646 has been moved is there
a second seconded by representative Hill
any other discussion from anybody on the
committee
not needed I think we beat it up but if
you if you want to
see none I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll when she's ready on retain the
Vice chairman of warski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Berry yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Sykes
yes representative rich
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative Holland yes
representative yes chairman Walsh yes
take a zero
okay
so
646 is retained and again as I mentioned
before uh as soon as we're allowed to
start working on this uh I'll start
scheduling some some work sessions on
the side anybody that wants to start
working on it doesn't stop you from
doing that anytime so I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 646.
uh and that's everything I had on the
schedule for today
um
first of all I'd like to thank everybody
that signed the card it was very nice it
has been a rough couple of weeks I truly
do thank you for that
um that does mean a lot
um
committee reports
I have I'm going to be looking for
committee reports before we leave the
building I do have copies if you want to
do them on paper or as as you you
hopefully still have
um the electronic form that was sent to
everybody last week
I have 374.
375 was retained right yep do you have
enough
um
so I think we're all good with the
majority reports are there any minority
just email them to me okay all right
yeah
uh if you can get them to me tonight
I'd like I'd like to submit them tonight
so because they there's a chance some of
them get on the calendar if they've got
them tonight
maybe
hopefully they don't have to
representative
do you have a question representative uh
yes we have house session on next
Tuesday so uh will we be trying to get
anything done around the schedule that
right here I don't think so so I'll look
at it I
we had a couple hours in the morning if
we needed to for any early bills but
seeing as how we've accomplished that
today we don't need that day
I'm leaning towards no for the 14th only
because of session
the question then would be do you want
the following week is that is that
school break
yeah
I was going to ask that school break is
the 27th week okay so then plan on
meeting back here on the 21st 21st okay
because we're in session the 23rd we
think and maybe the 22nd right but we
could be here on the 21st yeah okay
we're in pretty good shape we've only
got four more bills to hear okay so I'm
thinking
well I won't be too optimistic about one
more committee day but it's possible I
mean so four more here wow they're going
to be some long hearings so I think
we're going to need two more days but
again for our for our the other bills we
don't have to report out until March
16th so we have plenty of time thank you
Mr chair yes so on the calendar it says
that if on the 14th our committees could
meet in the afternoon after everything's
done over at the big Hall is that not a
possibility for us
well I'm down here so it doesn't matter
to me well that's a good point hold on
we are going to
do House business
do the budget address if that's over
we're gonna go back into doing bills if
we have any
yes it is
no you can't really unless the
designated time was at the end of
session because we don't know when
any other questions
all right thank you again everybody and
I'll be here